this week the war that President Putin
expected to last just three days
reaches a year in duration
Russian forces have killed thousands of
ukrainians 18 million ukrainians have
left their homes thousands have been
forcibly deported to Russia historic
cities
now lion ruins
Russia has targeted hospitals
schools and energy supplies and because
of Russia's blockade of Black Sea ports
and its economic blackmail
some of the world's poorest people are
now paying higher prices for food for
energy and for the means of survival
in the areas liberated from Russian
forces
the ukrainians have uncovered Mass
Graves
as well as evidence of rape and torture
on an unimaginable scale
Putin
is responsible for this
invasion was unprovoked and it was
illegal
he could stop it at once by withdrawing
his forces from Ukrainian land
but he is making the lives of millions
of people hell
for the sake of his Imperial delusions
he blundered into a war that he cannot
and will not win
ukrainians were always going to resist a
hostile attack aimed at wiping out their
country
early last year
in New York I predicted that if Putin
were foolish enough to invade Ukraine
that ukrainians would defend their
Homeland ferociously and I've been
Vindicated in that prediction
today
they are more unified more proud more
determined than ever and as president
zielinski said when he addressed my
honorable and right honorable friends
and those across the house here in
Westminster Hall on the 8th of February
freedom
will win
we and the whole world remain United and
Resolute in our support for Ukrainian
sovereignty and territorial integrity
and for the defense of the UN Charles I
will give away what Resolute are we are
we going to give them airplanes
are you sure my honorable friend and
I'll make reference to this later on in
my remarks
that the determination of the Ukrainian
people is
is unbounded and I will talk about what
further support we might give them if I
uh later on in my in my speech
Ukraine stand side by side in the face
of this aggression
we have become the closest of friends
and the most committed of Partners we
are inspired by their heroism and the
resilience of the Ukrainian people we
come together as never before we share
a common purpose
I will
I'm very grateful to this thank you stay
for giving away on that point and I'm
struck when I go out a year on about in
my constituency the support from the
British people despite the adversity
that they face with the cost of living
pressures going up that they still think
this is the right thing to do does the
Secretary say agree with me
the British people in every corner of
the United Kingdom have demonstrated a
generosity of spirit which is admirable
which should make every single member of
this house proud
Ukraine's heroic armed forces have
already recaptured thousands of square
miles from the Russians driving them out
of more than half of all the territory
that they grabbed last year
but Putin shows no sign of withdrawing
his forces
if we are to change his mind Ukraine
will need to take more land back
today
the Russian army is on the defensive
morale is pitiful casualties are immense
and their troops are running out of key
weapons and ammunition so this is
exactly the right moment for Ukraine to
seize the advantages that is why we and
our allies must step up our effort to
ensure that Ukraine wins this war and
secures a lasting peace Justice must be
served on those responsible for war
crimes and atrocities in accordance with
international law please the secretary
has made an outstanding start in this
debate last week the vice president of
the United States said that the United
States has formally determined
that Russia has committed crimes against
humanity has Her Majesty's government
now come formally to the same conclusion
we of course are looking very closely at
the evidence which is being compiled and
whilst we've not made a formal
designation I can assure him and other
honorable and writerable members from
across this house that we will ensure
those people who are accountable so
those people who are responsible for
atrocities whether they be in the field
or right up to the desk of Adam and
Putin himself will be held accountable I
I think the foreign secretary and thank
the fact that the government has moved
to freeze the assets of those Russians
engaged in supporting the Putin regime
but the EU has already set out a plan of
how they're going to move those frozen
assets into a rebuilding program for
Ukraine and our good friend and allies
the Canadians have also set out in
legislation how they will be doing that
so what what's causing the delay with
respect to the UK why have we dithered
While others have acted
The Honorable gentleman is mistaken in
his assessment of how far forward other
countries are in this of course we are
all looking at ensuring I'll make
reference to this further on the speech
we are all looking at how we can ensure
that the people responsible for this
damage ultimately pay for this damage
but the fact are he is wrong in terms of
how far forward other nations are with
regard to Canada I discussed this on my
recent visit to Canada with foreign
minister Jolie we have a similar legal
system and they are testing the legal
parameters and we will of course learn
from the experience that they have the
honorable gentleman and I'll make some
more progress
thank the minister very much for for his
response and it's a good positive hard
response and we expect that and thank
him for that uh it seems that reports
are filtering through in relation to the
systematic rape abuse and sexual uh
attacks upon women of all ages from his
youngest four to as old as 83 it's
systematic it's uh approved at the top
of government uh within Russia and
within the the trips when it comes to
taking action and collecting all the
evidence to ensure that those who
perpetrated these acts these deprived
and evil acts are made accountable I am
sure the minister will give us the
Assurance of this house needs but I
think we need it as a nation as well
thank you
The Honorable gentleman makes an
incredibly important point and uh again
I'll make reference to it later on in my
remarks but when I visited Kiev and
urban and spoke with the ukrainians and
when I also spoke with the ukrainians at
our preventing sexual violence conflict
uh conference uh here in London the
testimonies that I heard were genuinely
heartbreaking and I can assure him and
the house that they will not go
unpunished
friend give way
um I thank our iPhone friend we are
seeing atrocities as being fed by other
members in Ukraine terrible atrocities
that really in retrospect when this
whole awful situation that Ukraine are
in may be classified as a genocide this
isn't the first time that Russia have
undertaken a genocide it happened with
the halodemore in
1932-33 but we as a country don't
recognize it I hope that when this is
over as soon as possible we can look
again and reclassify the holotimal which
murdered millions of people as this one
is doing and recognize it formally as
many other countries do
my honorable friend makes an incredibly
important points and when I uh gave a
short press comments after my meeting
with
um foreign minister kaleba in Kiev I
made reference uh to that very uh Point
obviously it would be wrong to prejudge
how this is defined in the future
um but we we know because we've heard
Vladimir Putin say it himself but his
intention is to eradicate the whole
concept
of Ukraine
let me make let me make some more let me
make some more progress let me make some
progress because a number of a number of
the interventions have touched upon
things that I am planning to make in the
in the speech but I I assure my right on
my friend I will give him uh the uh the
opportunity to
um
creased Military Support to Ukraine is
the quickest
and therefore the most humane way to end
this war
I witnessed the extraordinary courage
and resolve of the Ukrainian people when
I traveled to Kevin Urban three months
ago I saw for myself
and I understand fully that they will
defend themselves and their land
whatever the cost may be they will never
give in they will never surrender
so Russia's untrained conscripts
sent to the front line of a war that
makes no sense to them will never never
be able to match Ukraine's martial
spirit this is why Ukraine is going to
win and this is why we must ensure that
they win as quickly as possible
Miss Deputy speaker the UK's military
humanitarian and economic supports
Ukraine since the invasion started has
reached nearly 4 billion pounds I want
to pay tribute and commend my
right-honorable friends the members for
Uxbridge and South ruislip and Southwest
Norfolk for the decisiveness and the
resolve in the early stages of this
conflict which gave ukrainians a
Fighting Chance enabled them to defend
their capital city and bought them the
time that they needed to push back the
Russian forces and I'm very glad that
the uh on the right honorable gentleman
the right honorable lady are in their
places here yeah yeah yeah
we are proud
to be the largest supplier of military
aids to the to Ukraine after the United
States of America we were the first
country to provide the weapons Ukraine
needed to defend itself in 2023
we shall at very least match the 2.3
billion pounds of military aid we gave
last year and we shall add more advanced
capabilities across land across sea and
across air
I'm most grateful to my arrived friend
um he referred to the importance of
holding Russia to account for its crimes
he will be aware of the actions already
underway both in the international
criminal court and by the Ukrainian
judicial system but can he confirm that
the government also now support the
establishment of a special International
tribunal to pursue Russia for the crime
of aggression
a very very important Point uh we have
joined the working group to look at a
special vehicle for a full
accountability because as I've said in
response to an intervention that's
already made it is not enough just to
hold to account for people committing
the rapes and the murder and the
brutality we must ensure that those
ordering them to do so and facilitating
that brutality are also held to account
my honorable am I right I sort of end
for giving away and he is quite right to
commend the heroism of the Ukrainian
Armed Forces which has been Second To
None our military aid is therefore
absolutely Paramount and we are right to
give it there is clearly a
continent-wide challenge which Embraces
all with data around our ammunition
supplies and our ability to sustain the
war effort in Ukraine in the way that's
going to be required can he commit that
we are reassessing as a matter of
urgency our defense stocks which must be
severely depleted at this juncture to
make sure we can sustain the effort
however long it takes
is right we need to support the
ukrainians until they are victorious and
the point I've made on the international
stage and I made this point at the
Munich security conference uh just at
the tail end of last week and over the
weekend
these equipments
this ammunition
was to fight in this theater
against that enemy
we are lucky
that the young men and young women who
were conducting that flight are
ukrainians rather than British
but therefore we have an enhanced duty
to ensure that they are successful and
if anyone in the uh International
Community or amongst our allies was
thinking of holding back their stocks
for a rainy day this is the rainbow yeah
yeah
I'll keep going I think it's interested
and leading on to that
um Biden has been there given 500
billion dollars to pledge further for
weapons we've given 2.3 billion from
there what message do we have for our
European colleagues and those across the
world to help support us to come forward
and make sure Ukraine is successful
well I have this conversation with NATO
allies uh and others and this is about
not just ensuring that Ukraine can
defend its sovereignty and territory and
people this is and I'll make this point
later on in my remarks this is about
defending the UN Charter and the
international order that has kept us
safe since the end of the uh of the last
war and that all countries that believe
in defending those principles should
make every effort to assist Ukraine this
time I will make some further progress
Miss Deputy speaker
we will give the Ukrainian forces the
upper hand on the battlefield so that
they can reverse Russia's gains and
limit Putin's ability to Target civilian
infrastructure we must also develop
their four structures and capability so
that they can build a deterrence Force
for the future
over the last six months we have trained
10 000 Ukrainian troops to bring them up
to battle Readiness and we will upskill
a further 20 000 this year and as my
right honorable friend the Prime
Minister announced last week we will
train Ukrainian fast jet pilots and
Marines as part of a long-term
investment in their military
capabilities
when the prime minister
uh let me let me make some more progress
when the Prime Minister and president
zielinski met earlier this month they
underscored our joint determination to
achieve a just and sustainable piece and
we shall work together in international
organizations to achieve that and to
defend the principles of the UN Charter
I am traveling to New York New York this
week to speak on Ukraine in the UN
Security Council I will tell the truth
about Putin's brutality and Ukraine's
heroism but we must also increase our
efforts with Partners to tackle the
steady drip of poisonous Russian
propaganda and lies and we will work
together
to help Ukrainian grain reach World
Markets the Black Sea grain initiative
and grain from Ukraine boost food
security for the world's most vulnerable
people I will and then Mr Deputy speaker
I thank my right honorable friend for
allowing me to intervene on the subject
of training Pilots
the aircraft that we have the lightning
and the typhoon are totally incompatible
with fighting in Ukraine they require
large sustainment and they operate from
bases well away from actually in theater
the aircraft that would be ideal perhaps
is the Gripen aircraft which the swedes
have we don't have people trained to be
able to train the trainers because we
don't have aircraft on which to train
them or simulate us to do it so slightly
concerned when my right honorable friend
says we're going to train Pilots because
I wonder how we'll do it
uh as my honorable and Gallant friend
knows I am a uh I'm a good old-fashioned
thick steamed Gunner so I understand
ballistic artillery and very little else
but I am assured I'm assured by my right
honorable friend the defense secretary
in close coordination with our Ukrainian
friends that the uh training
contribution that we are making is
genuinely valuable and very much valued
by them
Secretary of State for uh giving away it
said that water is easy it's peace
that's hard but that ignores the fact
that war is never easy and that peace is
a light that we must all attempt to
pursue and to avoid an escalation of
hostilities and he'll be aware that um
the uh of the crucial nature of the
Black Sea grain deal and the impact that
the devastation from the earthquake in
turkey and Syria will have on our
ability to maintain that can you tell us
what support has been offered to Turkey
um and what the UN is doing to secure
the position of Food Supplies to the
rest of the world
uh Mr Speaker he does make an important
point it's not directly linked to the uh
subject of the debate but I can reassure
him that I've been uh speaking I've been
in regular contact with
um the uh the Turkish uh foreign
minister with regard to our ongoing uh
support to Turkey uh and uh Northwest
Syria in their attempts to deal with the
terrible consequences of the
um of the earthquake uh at the time I
made a statement I uh committed to keep
the house uh informed I'll make sure I
do that
in uh I think I'm looking at the number
of people in the chamber I'm going to
try and make a bit more progress before
I do see
into our 2.3 billion of Military Support
we are providing more than 1.6 billion
in non-military assistance uh some 1.35
billion in lending guarantees through
the World Bank and the EB Rd the 100
million indirect budgetary assistance
and 220 million pounds of humanitarian
support I I I will I I want to make some
more progress because I can see there
are a number of people in the chain but
I have no doubt they'll want to they'll
want to speak progress otherwise I'll
get another missive
from
I'm very I'm very grateful to my
honorable friend
talking about Gunnery uh Mr Deputy
speaker the Iranian the ukrainians are
managing to maintain barrages of between
five thousand and six thousand shells
and Rockets per day and they're getting
probably 20 000 in from the from the
Russians that is equivalent to
a small NATO country's procurement
before the annual procurement before the
war started so is he confident that we
have the industrial capacity our sun the
Americans not only to maintain the level
of support and increase it to the
ukrainians but without diminishing our
own stops which are getting things
through them
uh the simple truth is that we have to
make sure that we provide ukrainians
with the ammunition they need to get the
job done our industrial base will have
to step up again I have no doubt but we
should be confident that as NATO allies
including of course the industrial might
of the United States America will
considerably outmark outmatch the
capability of the Russian Federation to
produce ammunition
I will make Pro give house Natures I
intend to make progress now
um our Vital humanitarian assistants
delivered through the United Nations Red
Cross and ngos is saving lives and
helping to protect the most vulnerable
in Ukraine and those forced to flee from
Russian attacks ongoing attacks on
civilian infrastructure underscores
Putin's increasing desperation and we
have provided 22 million pounds in
direct support to Ukraine's energy
sector this includes seven million for
over 850 generators to ensure vital
facilities like hospitals have I'm going
to make progress
um and uh and five million pounds for
Safety and Security equipment for the
Civil nuclear sector we're working
closely with International Partners to
reduce their energy dependence on Russia
the UK phased out Russian coal from
August of last year and banned Imports
of Russian liquefied natural gas from
the start of this year and alongside the
G7 in Australia in December we set a
price cap on seaborne Russian crude oil
to restrict Putin's primary source of
revenue for his illegal War
despite elevated oil prices
Russia's finance ministry has reported a
47 billion dollar deficit in 2022
because of the decisive action that we
have taken and we will continue
to work with Partners to cut off
Russia's hydrocarbon revenues and
accelerate the global transition to
clean reliable sources of power and
we've also Imports we've also imposed
our largest and most severe package of
sanctions ever against Russia
with our allies we have frozen over
275 billion pounds worth of Russian
assets
in addition to the 1 200 individual
individuals already sanctioned we will
introduce new measures against those in
Russia and outside it who are supporting
or profiteering from this war and we
will crack down ruthlessly on those who
seek to evade sanctions
abuses and violations of human rights
have been committed by Russian forces on
a systematic scale
torture and killing of civilians rape
and sexual violence as a weapon of War
forced deportations we will not allow
these crimes to go unpunished we will
support the war crimes investigations
both of the Ukrainian authorities and
the international criminal court and the
UK
will host a major international meeting
to support the ICC investigating alleged
war crimes in Ukraine in March of this
year
when this war over when this war is over
Ukraine can never again be left
vulnerable to attack a strong Ukraine
must be safe flourishing and prosperous
with our Ukrainian friends we will
co-host the 2023 Ukraine recovery
conference on the 21st 22nd of June here
in London together we plan to mobilize
the combined might of public and finance
public and private Finance to ensure
that Ukraine gets the vital
reconstruction investment
that it needs and I know this house will
join me in calling upon Putin to
withdraw Russian forces from Ukrainian
territory and immediately bring an end
to the barbaric attacks against
civilians
this Deputy speaker
the ukrainians have endured months of
Relentless attacks and bombardment
but their spirits is unbroken and we
share their determination that Putin's
illegal attempted Invasion will fail and
that this house demands that Justice be
done yeah
[Music]
question is of this house has considered
the situation in Ukraine Shadow foreign
secretary David London
[Music]
the deputy speaker one year ago we
gathered in this chamber fearing the
worst
I had
alongside the shadow defense secretary
just returned from Keith
Russian forces were masked on Ukraine's
border
the intelligence picture was bleak
Specter of Tanks rolling across the
borders of 21st century Europe
seemed both inconceivable
and yet imminent
on the 24th of February 2022
that was a dark day for Europe
that morning
President Putin launched the largest
conflict on our continent since the
Second World War
an illegal
unprovoked and unjustifiable War of
choice
that has left tens of thousands dead
Millions displaced from their homes
billions worth of damage inflicted on
Ukraine's infrastructure families torn
apart land mines thrown across whether
once golden fields
and a dark trail of atrocities
pop marking the Ukrainian Countryside
Putin believed this would be a short war
he thought it would be an easy War
he thought Ukraine would fault without a
fight
perhaps in his warped world view
because he thought these Russian
Invaders would be welcomed
as liberators
he thought the West was weak and divided
and Mr Deputy speaker he was wrong on
every count
instead Putin's Folly has been met with
unity and strength
ukrainians have paid a bitter price for
this war
but they have defended their land with
courage
Ingenuity and that Relentless commitment
that comes from a righteous cause
Russia stands isolated and condemned on
the international stage
its economy humstrung by severe
sanctions
NATO rather than weakened has been
strengthened and invigorated with new
members posed to Joy
the transatlantic Alliance has stayed
United and this house too has stood
United
that was the message that President
zielinski received when he visited
Westminster it was a message that
kirstama took to Keith personally last
week Britain stands United behind
Ukraine
and in that spirit I want to pay tribute
to the foreign secretary and the defense
secretary and to our two former Prime
Ministers who deserve credit for the
roles that they have played
on Britain's military help to Ukraine
and on reinforcing NATO allies the
government has had and will continue to
have Labor's fullest support
thank you I'll remember the giving way
is a pertinent debate to have because
the leader opposition wasn't the only
Member of Parliament who was in Ukraine
last week myself was there I took 112
112 generators to the people of Ukraine
along with six other constituents we
have worked tirelessly since December to
raise nearly 40 000 pounds to take aid
there uh there was a bomb the night that
we were in live luckily we were all safe
and on our return Journey we took a
little girl uh her mother and their pet
back to the United Kingdom to a host
family in Guildford because they had
their home destroyed well I'd say to The
Honorable member this government has
done an awful lot of work to help the
people of Ukraine but will he also pay a
tribute to Everyday men and women
throughout the entire United Kingdom
including my constituents who have
literally given up their day jobs to
raise money and take humanitarian Aid to
the people of Ukraine who they stand
shoulder to shoulder and I can say now
the people we met the aid agency
absolutely the resolve and The Bravery
of those people I met is unshakable
well The Honorable gentleman is
absolutely right in sometimes fractious
times in our country the spirit
of the British people their generosity
has no no bounds their compassion is
humbling
and their desire to continue to stand
steadfast
alongside the Ukrainian people really
really is a tribute to our nation
we can also all be proud of the role our
armed forces are playing in training
Ukrainian forces we can be proud of the
contribution of our diplomats and our
brilliant Ambassador Melinda Simmons on
the ground in Keith
and we can be proud of the way British
families as has been said have opened
their homes
two ukrainians fleeing war and supported
their cause from home
Mr Deputy speaker Putin's war in Ukraine
marks the end of the post-cold War era
and we need a new mindset for these
challenging times
the last year has Illustrated some
pretty hard lessons
first
it's laid bare how naive
and complacent we've been in terms of
Russian malign intent in this country
and others
The Invasion exposed a decade of chronic
inaction against dirty money from Russia
and other authority authorian States
that saw Kremlin linked oligarchs and
kleptocrats use London as both the
hiding place and service industry for
their ill-gotten gains
it should never have taken the invasion
of Ukraine to act and while some
progress has been made the job is far
from done
labor will continue to hold the
government to account until Britain is
no longer a soft touch for illicit
Finance
second is the defense secretary himself
conceded
for a decade we have hollowed out an
underfunded our Armed Forces
many in Europe believe the era of Wars
between States was over we reshaped our
security defense intelligence and
diplomacy to tackle different threats
allowing core capabilities to dwindle
even when Putin broke international law
and invaded his neighbors our responses
were weak that must change beginning
with the immediate need for stockpile's
strategies to sustain support for
Ukraine and re-arm Britain
third Mr Deputy speaker we must never
of course I'll give way
it's very grateful as somebody not alone
who has called on both front benches for
a very long time to commit to three
percent of GDP to be spent on defense a
figure that we were still spending in
the mid-1990s after the end of the Cold
War
I'm very used to hearing people when
they're not in a position saying we need
to spend more can we have an assurance
that if he ever were in the position of
power we would reach three percent of
GDP as a minimum on defense
well I'm very grateful to the chair of
the uh intelligence elect committee uh
for all that he has said on this issue
over many years we have committed in my
party to a defense review on day one if
we were to come to office and I gently
remind him that throughout our previous
period in office spending on defense per
capita was higher than it's been today
it was standing at 2.5 percent when we
left office we are seeing what is
happening a across the European
continent with
so many European countries committed to
spending more and committed to spending
um
the three percent that he is indicating
we must play our part
alongside France as 50 percent of
Europe's defense capability
I thank my right honorable friend the
shadow foreign secretary for giving way
and indeed he will be aware of reports
of a Russian attempts to subvert
moldovan democracy and interfere within
their political institutions which could
have far-reaching consequences for the
war in Ukraine and broader European
security does he agree with me that the
UK government must act urgently to
support Moldova and its democracy before
uh situation worsens
well my honorable friend is absolutely
right
to raise the issue of Moldova and its
vulnerability at this time and I I fully
suspect other members to return to this
issue across the course of this debate
they are feeling very worried
on this year this year later since the
War Began and we must stand with them as
well and our friends write also to refer
to the cyber terrorism that has become a
benchmark of Putin's aggression
alongside it
third Mr Deputy speaker we must never
again allow ourselves to become
dependent on autocrats and their fossil
fuels for our energy
decarbonization is now a vital National
Security imperative the faster we can
transition to clean power the quicker we
can undermine Putin's war effort every
solar power
panel is a shield to Putin's aggression
every windfall a defense against
dependency and in developing our
homegrown Energy Systems we can build a
green job
jobs in the transformational industry of
the future
fourth Mr Deputy speaker it's a reminder
of the essential relationship with our
European allies
we have shared interests shared
geography and common values with our
neighbors in Europe NATO will always be
the anchor of our defense and the
Cornerstone of European security but
it's more important than ever that we
have strong diplomatic Partnerships with
our European allies and that we have a
close Cooperative relationship with the
EU itself this is too serious
too serious a time to be starting
unnecessary fights or engaging in Petty
diplomatic squabbles
Mr Deputy speaker as we approach the
one-year anniversary of this war it's
obvious that we're entering a new and
dangerous phase
last week NATO and Western intelligence
agencies warned that Putin had started
amassing fighter jets and helicopters
near the Ukrainian border a sign that as
we enter spring Putin is adopting a new
approach to the war
which could see greater use of Russian
air power to support its faltering land
defensive but in recent days both
Ukrainian and NATO officials have warned
that ammunition shortages
dwindling domestic stockpiles and Supply
chains under increased pressure
if Ukraine is going to Prevail over what
Putin will throw at it the UK and our
allies should set aside individual
announcements and instead lay out a
long-term strategy to provide the
support that Ukraine needs whether it be
ammunition additional air defense
capabilities or NATO standard Weaponry
we need to ensure that Ukraine has our
total support to tackle the Russian
threat from air and land
and alongside this military assistance
we need a new diplomatic drive to
sustain and broaden the Diplomatic
Coalition against this war
Russia's invasion was an attack not just
on Ukraine but on the international
order itself it's perhaps the most
egregious violation of the UN Charter
since it was written a sovereign U.N
member invaded by a permanent member of
the security Council we need to work
with Ukraine and partners around the
world to make clear the truth of this
war and counter Putin's propaganda to
make clear it is Russia that has chosen
this war that Russia is the aggressor
and that it's Russia who is willing to
use Global hunger as a bargaining chip
that it's Russia that's trying to change
International borders through force and
that we will be less secure if that
aggression is allowed to succeed
but Mr Deputy speaker our support for
Ukraine must entail action at home as
well as abroad at home here in the UK we
must complete the job and get out our
get our own house in order that means
tackling Putin's kleptocracy it means
closing the loopholes that continue to
exist in our sanctions regime it means
properly enforcing our own laws around
illicit finance and Mr Deputy speaker we
will go still further Russian rockets
and Iranian drones have destroyed
Ukraine's hospitals energy plants and
homes whole Villages and towns and
cities to dust reduced to rubble and
ruin by some estimates the damage to
infrastructure is more than a hundred
billion without proper funding the
essential task of rebuilding Ukraine
will take decades to complete as long
ago as July 2022 the then foreign
secretary the right honorable member for
Southwest Norfolk said that the
government supported using Frozen
Russian assets to support Ukraine
but since then we've heard nothing
sure right honorable lady will refer to
that in her speech later the EU has
already set out a plan to shift frozen
assets into a fund to help rebuild
Ukraine and Canada as has been said is
already legislated to do it so why
hasn't our government done the same
Mr Deputy speaker ukrainians don't have
the luxury of time this is an urgent
point and so I asked the foreign
secretary once more what steps has this
government taken since July 2022 to
ensure that seized Russian State assets
can be used for the benefit of Ukraine
further to this will the government
support the bill put forward by the
right honorable family member for Ronda
which would allow for Russian State
assets to be used for this same purpose
a Mr Deputy speaker throughout the
horrific last 12 months the body of
evidence of Russian war crimes in
Ukraine has grown and grown on a weekly
basis we hear horrific reports of mass
Graves discovered in liberated areas on
the TV we see sickening videos of
schools hospitals and churches being
bombed to destruction of innocent
civilians murdered and tortured these
crimes demand accountability and they
demand Justice we strongly support all
International efforts to document
investigate and prosecute these crimes
but again we believe we should go
further since March labor has been
calling on the government to support the
creation of a special tribunal to
prosecute Putin and his top brass for
the crime of aggression the foreign
secretary knows that while the ICC can
investigate war crimes committed in
Ukraine it cannot investigate Russia for
the crime of aggression only a special
tribunal working alongside the ICC could
ensure this gap of accountability is
bridged the Ukrainian people want this
Tribunal zelenski wants this tribunal
the EU commission wants this tribunal
along with France Germany Estonia Latvia
and countless more who have called for
it so will the foreign secretary commit
to its creation and if so what steps has
he taken to make it happen
and finally Mr Deputy speaker Putin's
invasion of Ukraine has demonstrated
more clearly than ever before how our
Securities connected with the security
of the rest of Europe
past 12 months have shown vividly that
all that can be achieved when we stand
United with our allies on the other side
of the channel
I'm grateful to you friends made a
brilliant speech this afternoon was he
as surprised as I was that there was so
little mention
um of this kind of threat in the
integrative review and would he support
the call the the next iteration of that
integration review has absolutely got to
put the recontainment of Russia Center
Stage
or my right honorable friend is
absolutely right and has been crystal
clear on this from the back benches we
await that into independent review this
has got to be Central we've got to get
it right and obviously we'll scrutinize
it in every detail in many of the areas
that have been critical to supporting
Ukraine defend herself against Russia
sanctions energy security and defense
our cooperation with the European Union
has been critical
to our support for Ukraine and through
to through that Ukraine's survival
I'll just make a little progress it's
more important than ever that we have
strong structured mechanisms for
dialogue and cooperation with our allies
in Europe and that is why labor have
proposed a new UK EU security pact that
could cover deeper cooperation on both
foreign policy defense and security and
law enforcement Mr Deputy speaker
Labor's commitment to Nato is unshakable
yet the UK's leadership in Naco could be
at risk without growing concerns over
our capacity to meet NATO's full
obligations while 20 NATO Nations have
revised their defense strategies since
the start of the invasion the government
has not done so so I asked the foreign
secretary will the government commit to
rebooting our defense plans and will it
halt its planned cuts to the British
army
I thank my honorable friend for giving
way and support all that's been said
about the need for a long-term plan and
for defeating Putin and seeing Justice
Done will he he agree with me that the
cause of Ukrainian Civil Society to have
more support for their lawyers and
judges on the ground for those tens of
thousands of cases that can be tried in
Ukrainian courts should be heard and the
cause for psychosocial support for those
ukrainians who are going through trauma
but need to be rebuilt and supported
once Putin has been defeated
I'm very grateful to my honorable friend
earlier last month I spent time
with women
in Kosovo
reminding me of the horrors of war and
sexual violence
and in their own pain the work they were
doing to to help their Ukrainian sisters
at this desperate time it reminded me of
the importance of that psycho social
support and the huge humanitarian effort
that we and others must play their part
in not just over the next months but for
many many many years to come
uh inevitably some people will flee the
Russian uh advance that is coming in
this spring and some of those people
might be the the United Kingdom does he
agree with me that proper provision must
be made to welcome these people and also
to find permanent accommodation for them
if necessary
we honorable gentleman uh is right and
it's the reason so many British people
have opened their homes
two ukrainians at this desperate time
and of course as this new offensive
begins there will most likely be further
need over the coming months
Mr Deputy speaker
it's important to stress
that this war did not begin for the
ukrainians one year ago
it in fact begun in 2014 when Putin
moved into the donbaths and when he
annexed Crimea
but one year ago we hope for the best
yet we faced
what we seem to be
unsurmountable odds we feared the worst
but Ukraine stands defiant
the price ukrainians have paid for their
continued freedom is immense tens of
thousands have lost
cities destroyed
family shattered while Ukraine Stands
Tall Putin stands condemned and isolated
while Ukraine has won the admiration and
respect of the world Putin's ego has
made Russia a pariah while Putin
expected the West to fracture and divide
his actions have drawn us together but
Mr Deputy speaker we cannot become
complacent in the coming weeks and
months Ukraine will yet again face new
challenges and hardships designed by
Putin to test her resolve and the
resolve us all it is our duty to the
people of Ukraine to do all we can to
ensure the country overcomes these
challenges in the same way it has all
the others Ukraine must
and will prevail
Boris Johnson thank you Mr Deputy
speaker and I want to pay tribute both
of the foreign secretary into the shadow
foreign secretary I think for the
quality of their speeches that we've
heard this afternoon in the year since
Vladimir Putin launched his vicious
unnecessary war in Ukraine he has failed
in almost all his objectives he's failed
to take Kiev he's been sent scutting
from the kharkiv region he's been forced
to evacuate her son he has crossed the
lives of at least 60 000 Russian troops
and uh with probably over a hundred
thousand injured in the areas he is
occupied in Ukraine he's created a new
Flanders Fields of modern trenches and
blasted trees where months of high
intensity shelling and bloodshed produce
gains that could be measured in yards
he's been forced to such desperate
expedience of sending prisoners to the
front or terrified members of ethnic
minorities recruited from remote
provinces and as my right on the foreign
secretary appointed out in his is his
powerful speech he is running pitifully
low on the technically Advanced Weaponry
that he increasingly needs the seemingly
irresistible force of the Russian
military is breaking Mr Deputy speaker
on the immovable object of Ukrainian
resistance and we in this house remain
lost in our admiration for the
ukrainians for their heroism and for the
continued inspiration that they are
given by President Vladimir zielinski
and yet it remains all too possible
the Putin can still achieve something
that he can call a victory
all that he needs to do is to hang on to
some piece of land that he has conquered
and the signal will go around the world
that aggression can pay and that borders
can be changed by force all he needs to
do to claim some kind of Victory is to
continue the cynical policy he's
followed since the first invasion of
2014 which has had a foreign secretary
rightly dwelt on to use his foothold in
Ukraine to destabilize the whole country
unless he's purged from Ukrainian
territory he will twist his knife in the
wound he will bite his time he will wait
until he can attack again he will
continue to Menace the lives of the
Georgians of the moldovans as The
Honorable member rightly pointed out the
bolts and everyone living on the
periphery of the old Soviet Empire
unless he is finally defeated in Ukraine
Putin's revanchist Ambitions will be
unchecked and that is why it is so
crucial that we now accelerate our
support for Ukraine and give them the
tools to finish the job we can all be
proud of what the government successive
governments have done uh to help this to
help the ukrainians and their Armed
Forces continue to fight like lions if
you just they who deserve the credit uh
but being no doubt Western Equipment has
been invaluable and the story of the
last 12 months
is that sooner or later
having exhausted all the other options
we give them what they need from
anti-tank missiles to high Mars to tanks
and so if that is the choice sooner or
later then For Heaven's Sake let's give
these weapons sooner
it's absurd for Western supporters to
keep asking the ukrainians as they were
pressed at the Munich security
conference how long is this going to
take
the answer to that question is to a
large extent determined by us
it is a fine thing that we finally
promised tanks but there is no
conceivable ground for delay in getting
them to Ukraine we need those machines
Abraham's Challengers leopards to make a
real difference in real time in the next
few weeks not next year
it's admirable that we're proposing to
train Ukrainian fighters to fly NATO
fast Jets I hear the uh the caution of
my honorable friend but it's curious
that we're doing this before we even
taken the decision in principle to give
them the planes let's cut to the Chase
and give them the planes too and uh if
the house was in any doubt about the
urgency
of increasing our supply of equipment to
the ukrainians it is becoming ever
clearer that China is preparing to arm
the Russians
the ukrainians have shown what they can
do they have the Elon and the courage to
sweep Putin from their lands and they
have the inestimable psychological
advantage that they are fighting for
half and home with the right kit
including more long-range artillery
artillery they can punch through the
land bridge cut off Crimea and deal a
knockout blow to Putin's plans and they
should not stop there
it is time for us all to end our
obfuscation
about what we think of as a Ukrainian
Victory and what we think of as Ukraine
the ukrainians need to be helped to
restore not just the borders of February
the 24th last year but the 1991 borders
on which they voted for Independence
it was the West's Collective weakness in
2014 the effective acquiescence in
Putin's aggression which helped to
convince him that he could launch an
attack last year and whatever the good
intentions of the Normandy format we
cannot say that that process that format
uh was a success nor frankly can we say
that the UK was right to have sent
ourselves from uh that uh formatting
from those discussions and we must not
make that mistake again
after a year of Slaughter we need to be
doing more collectively to show the
people of Russia what they are losing by
Putin's Miss rule which should be
tightening the sanctions of oil and gas
wherever we can and what I hear the
arguments that uh members are making
about the need to use frozen assets
whatever the complexities I think the
house deserves to hear those arguments
properly thrashed out we should be
making it clear to Putin's entire War
Machine as well as the regime in the
Kremlin that they will be held to
account for their crimes the torture
rape and indiscriminate killing that
they have sponsored we must show them
the Mills of Justice grind slowly but
they grind small we should designate
Russia as a state sponsor of terrorism
placing that country where it now
rightly belongs in the list that
includes Cuba North Korea and Syria and
by the way we should designate the
infamous and bloodthirsty Wagner group
as a foreign terrorist organization it
is a badge that is now rich deserved and
long overdue but above all I'm I'm just
winding up Mr Speaker but above all we
must give the ukrainians what they need
to win this war this year by ensuring
that Ukraine wins and that Putin fails
we are making the best and the most
financially efficient investment in the
long-term security not just of the
euro-atlantic area but of the whole
world we all know that we in this
country made a promise to Ukraine under
the 1994 Budapest memorandum when the
ukrainians gave up their vast nuclear
arsenal we said we would come to their
aid in the event of an attack now is the
time finally to do what we can to honor
that promise the ukrainians are not just
fighting for their freedom but for the
cause of Freedom around the world we
should give them what they need not next
month not next year but now hey joking
thank you Mr Deputy speaker I want to um
start by echoing much of what's been
said it's very rare for us to be in in
this place in a Accord with one another
and Ukraine's would that it wasn't the
case that we didn't have to talk about
it at all but it is and we are in full
Accord I want to touch on some
International comparators if I can
Estonia propose an eu-wide ammunition
purchase program for supplying Ukraine
um and I wonder I mean it doesn't have
to be the EU Mr Deputy speaker but
became pan-european is probably a more
helpful term in this legislature or pan
NATO something that will increase the
coordination uh and uh depth of their
ongoing ammunition delivery program I
don't want to see that in any way to
undermine that which has been achieved
going forward but it's quite clear that
Russia is looking to prosecute a war of
attrition going on for a very long time
and it would be hell helpful to
demonstrate to the Kremlin that the West
will meet that with renewed a Resurgence
in its supplies to Ukraine of course
doing that depletes the United Kingdom's
uh defense supplies and the supply chain
has been caught shot not their fault Mr
Deputy speaker but that of a slightly
less than Strategic Defense procurement
plan
um dating by many defense procurement
ministers I hasten to add and but we
must ensure that we step that up and get
renewed Pace into that Norway
interestingly have now passed a
five-year 6.15 billion pound Ukraine
support package the terms of which that
will be expended is to be done in
concert obviously with those in Ukraine
and I wonder whether the UK should seek
to emulate that with ring fenced
dedicated funds over the next five years
to send again a strong message I'm not
saying this to the foreign secretary to
somehow say that the UK hasn't chipped
in of course it has many billions of
pounds and no small measure of moral
support as well but I think these
measures would help to show Putin that
we're not going away and we are not
shrinking from The Challenge however he
wishes to present it going forward
Canada as has been touched on by other
members has changed a lot to allow the
seizure of Russian funds and has started
the process of seizing a first batch of
Frozen funds to send to Ukraine the UK
should follow suit in no short order and
I do wonder what progress the fun
Commonwealth and development office has
made with their friends in India to sort
to to to to demonstrate to them that it
is not acceptable to ride two horses in
this way that Russia's criminality
cannot just be dealt with by turning a
blind eye or holding your nose on the
altar of cheap oil prices you're either
in the rules-based International System
or you're not and I wonder if that
information has been conveyed in their
most robust terms by the United Kingdom
to India China is a concern Mr Deputy
speaker we need in the west to develop a
narrative that goes beyond cultural
differences that is not open to
interpretation and that lays it out
extremely clearly to Beijing the if they
ever were to make the miscalculation to
supply Russia with arms and Munitions
and other supplies that would help them
prolong this egregious invasion of
Ukraine then they will be met with very
significant consequences from the west
and I'd be very interested to know
what the United Kingdom government is
doing in that respect Russia of course
itself
I'll get on to air power in a minute Mr
Deputy speaker but the threat of
escalation is a material one and it's
one that we should pay close
concentration towards but we have over
the last 12 months perhaps
understandably mothered over the
definition of whether something is
lethal or defensive whether it's
tactical or strategic and now we've
moved that on to air power
Ukraine has received an extraordinarily
large amount of financial support and
Military assistance but there is a
pattern perhaps relieving interview
whereby Ukraine gets the weapons that
was asking for previously as it's asking
for the next set of weapons and I wonder
whether we should redouble our focus on
what whether or which we can do to
support Ukraine with air power
in terms of logistics as I've mentioned
the West is running out certainly United
Kingdom is running out of surplus or
even stores in ready use and further
equipment purchases will need to be done
but I don't have confidence Mr Deputy
speaker that the supply chain of the
defense procurement apparatus has exists
currently in the United Kingdom is up to
that job and I would welcome any
reassurance that the Secretary of State
can give me in that regard
a multi we should in the United Kingdom
come up to a multi-year spending package
ring fenced money to support Ukraine
again that would provide the most
clearest message possible I am pleased
up to a certain extent that the United
Kingdom is training combat air Pilots
for Ukraine but I am left wondering to
what end and I am also wondering what is
happening to the combat air pilots in
training with the Royal Air Force some
of whom I'm not making this up Mr Deputy
speaker some of whom are having to wait
eight or even nine years to become
qualified so what is the knock-on effect
of training Ukraine's combat air Pilots
That's not to say that it's not the
right thing to do but every action has
an equal but opposite reaction and we
should see the whole picture before we
celebrate perhaps prematurely
oh well I will indeed
it's the fastjet training program that
he's referring to which is known as mfts
is broken and everyone involved in
aviation knows it
but we also have some tranche one
typhoons
that have a lot of air time left in
their airframes sitting in a warehouse
that have now been taken out of Aria's
service does he agree with me that a
squadron of those given to the
ukrainians would do a lot more to defend
Freedom as my right honorable friend was
suggesting a few moments ago
than sitting in a warehouse Gathering
dust
well the right honorable gentleman makes
a valuable point and he does ask a
direct creation prayer that I agree with
him and I'm afraid I don't because it's
my understanding that tranche one
typhoons are they may have hours left
but they are
um by the time you apply the penalty
factors for what they did when they were
flying you won't find very many hours
left and they're also although they look
like a typhoon they're very old in terms
of the combat year systems and I think
maybe
um they're not exactly what Ukraine is
looking for but it's nevertheless a
valid point which leads me directly on
to my next point which is there is not a
single typhoon in the United Kingdom
available for use by Ukraine which makes
me wonder what we are training them on
unless we're training them on on on NATO
on NATO combat areas and NATO combat air
standard protocol that's all we can do
because they won't be getting typhoons
you mark my words and actually they
don't want typhoons because people talk
about we need to get Pilots for Ukraine
Pilots is just the tip of the arrowhead
you need all the maintenance Crews there
they're not avionics Specialists they're
refuelers the armorers the logistic tail
for a fourth generation combat aircraft
is enormously long and none are quite as
long as the typhoons so what they
actually need is something murakin to
grip in or f-16s and the United Kingdom
doesn't have any of these but that just
that means that the United Kingdom is
just part of the puzzle to work with
allies in nato in Europe and gripping in
particular is ideally suited to the
types of facilities that Ukraine will be
able to operate from so in conclusion uh
Mr Deputy speaker
the Secretary of State said that Ukraine
must take back
must take land back I think was his it
was what he had what was what he said
and I I wonder how he intends for
Ukraine to do that without exercising
air superiority uh and there will be as
I think most members in this house agree
there will be a spring offensive Mr
Deputy speaker we need to make sure that
that offensive belongs to Ukraine
just a reminder all members that if you
are taking part in the debate not an
intervention but a speech then you will
be expected to be here for the wind-ups
thank you very much Liz truss
Mr Deputy speaker
one year ago on Friday
I got a phone call at 3 30 in the
morning
from my private sector at the foreign
office
telling me that Vladimir Putin had begun
a whole scale Invasion into Ukraine
both airstrikes and a land Invasion
targeting cities across the country
including Kiev
this was devastating news
but as well as being devastating
it was not unexpected
we'd been seeing for months the way that
troops were being amassed on the border
of Ukraine
and we had very good intelligence
showing us exactly what Putin's plans
had been
we tried for months to forestall that
invasion
at the Liverpool G7 Summit back in 2021
we worked with our allies to come up
with a package of severe sanctions and
we warned Russia that these would be put
in place in the event of an invasion
for the first time in our history we
unveiled intelligence about what the
Russians were planning
they were planning to install a puppet
regime in Kiev
they were planning to install false flag
operations with a view to trying to
convince the world that it wasn't their
fault that they they invaded Ukraine
that they had been provoked and our
intelligence prevented the world
believing that
and from the year of 2015 we had started
training Ukrainian troops but also we
were the first European country to
supply weapons to Ukraine
we'd also called out Russia
internationally I personally visited
Moscow as did many of my counterparts to
give the message directly
to Sergey lavrov and others in the
Russian administration of the severe
consequences of their actions but
nevertheless
Putin went ahead despite the warnings
despite
what he knew would happen he went ahead
because fundamentally he didn't believe
the ukrainians would fight
and he didn't believe that the Free
World would have the resolve to stand up
to him
now he was proved wrong
in both cases and from day one
we saw sheer bravery on the part of
ukrainians defending their country
and we saw an Administration in Keith
who many people had expected to leave
their posts they'd expected zielinski in
his cabinet to flee the country they
didn't they stayed there and I remember
being on a video conference that evening
with the defense secretary and with our
counterparts who weren't in Poland they
weren't in the United States they were
in Keith
and they were defending their country
and asking us for our help with what we
could do and we did do all that we could
we together with our allies not just in
the G7 but around the world everywhere
from Australia to Singapore to
Switzerland we put on the toughest
sanctions and we push back the Russian
economy by decades
we also supplied weapons to Ukraine and
many around this chamber have commented
that maybe we should have supplied
weapons earlier but I can tell you from
working inside the government that we
did all we could as quickly as we could
to persuade our lives and we have built
up now an alliance of countries
supplying those weapons and I can't wait
to see the tanks and I can't wait to see
the fighter jets in Ukraine to help
those Brave ukrainians we also
coordinated with our allies in
international response
and at the United Nation 141 countries
stood up against Russian in Russian
invasion and what Russia had done and
that too was unprecedented
but let's all be honest
we should have done more earlier
the reason
that Putin
took the action He took is because he
didn't believe we would follow through
and we didn't take him at his word as
far back in 2007 at the Munich security
conference Putin made it very clear what
his intentions were
he is taught on many occasions about
creating a greater Russia
he took action As We Know
on Crimea on the donbass but we didn't
do enough
we let it pass we collectively turned
far too much of a blind eye
we also I'm afraid to say and I this is
not just the United Kingdom this is
Europe This Is The Free World
we imported Russian gas and oil
we saw money flow in from Russia
money
that was later to be used to buy the
weapons that would be used against the
Ukrainian people
and we also failed to take action on
defending Ukraine now my colleague uh
the member for Oxbridge commented on
sorry the right honorable of course
right honorable member Oxford comment
I'm sorry about that I do apologize
[Laughter]
let's be honest I should have more
respect after
well as my right honorable friend
commented earlier
we signed the 1994 Budapest memorandum
it's guaranteed the security of Ukraine
so we should have provided more weapons
to Ukraine and I believe we should have
allowed Ukraine to join NATO can we
imagine this situation if Ukraine had
been a NATO member under Article 5
protection this would simply not happen
I will give way
the 1994 Budapest Accords also was
signed by Russia it was that guaranteed
the sovereignty of Ukraine absolutely so
Russia is is to blame as well absolutely
right well in America I completely agree
with my honorable friend that Russia is
of course to blame
but we should hold ourselves to high
standards and we should follow through
on commitments that we have made and so
should our other allies like the United
States and I feel that this is
unfinished business in terms of offering
Ukraine the security that they needed
and that is why I believe we need to
learn the lessons from what has happened
because frankly
we were complacent about freedom and
democracy after the Cold War we were
told it was the end of history and that
freedom and democracy were guaranteed
and we could carry on
living Our Lives not really worrying
about what else had happened that there
wouldn't be a challenge to those basic
principles that we'd won the argument
I think we know now that that argument
is never finally won absolutely and we
need to keep winning the argument we
need to keep defending our values with
hard security and economic security if
we are to succeed so first of all we
need to do all we can to make sure
Ukraine wins this war as soon as
possible every extra day
our lives lost
women violated
towns destroyed
we need to do all we can as fast as we
can my view is that does include fighter
jets and we've had a discussion today
about which are the best possible
options
having spoken to the ukrainians about
this months and months ago I know what
they want is an option they want so
let's work with our allies to get them
an option to be able to use because
otherwise they won't be able to prevail
and we also need to make sure that they
have the economic wherewithal to
continue the fight and we need to make
sure we're continuing to support them
internationally as well
but the second thing the second thing we
need to do
is not be complacent when that war is
won because I do believe Ukraine will
win this War I think there is no way
that Russia will win the war
but we need to make sure
the the future of Russia
is a more positive future than the one
we enabled at the end of the Cold War
right and what what does that mean well
first of all
it means never again becoming complacent
in the face of Russian money Russian oil
and gas instead making sure that any
lifting of sanctions is tied to reform
in Russia we can never have the
situation again where we enable freedom
and
free
free trade between the west and Russia
and that is then used to develop a
kleptocracy which is exactly what we
have seen take place
and we also need to make sure
that Russia pays for the crimes it is
committed the appalling atrocities of
war crimes need to be held to the count
all of them we need to make sure that
money seized from the Russian state
is used to rebuild Ukraine that to me is
vitally important of course we in
well-off countries like Britain should
should contribute
but I cannot imagine a situation where
Russia can simply
go ahead as if nothing had happened and
don't contribute to rebuilding Ukraine I
think that is absolutely vital and I
will be pushing for that to happen
operations
but the third thing we need to learn
is about how we deal with authoritarian
regimes more broadly
a presidency
has made it very very clear about his
intentions with respect to Taiwan
we have to take these seriously now
during the Russia
Ukraine conflict The Invasion by Russia
of Ukraine we have amassed for the first
time in history a group of Nations who
are prepared to put on sanctions who are
prepared to act together
we need to formalize this grouping I've
described it as an economic NATO the G7
plus RT allies like the EU like South
Korea like Australia we need to bring
that group together
and start developing our plans now
because what we know
is that we ended up doing these things
after
the invasion of Ukraine and my view is
prevention is far better than cure so
let's develop these economic tools and
let's be clear with China exactly what
would happen if there was an escalation
with respect to Taiwan let's be clear
about that now
and let's also make sure that Taiwan is
able to defend itself
let's not leave another free democracy
undefended for an authoritarian regime
to invade
that for me is a very important
principle
because the reality is
there are fewer people as a proportion
of the world's population living under
democracy Now
than there were 30 years ago
can we imagine
what the world will look like in 30
years time
if we don't act now it's not a world I
want to live in
I think we've heard some excellent
contributions to the debates and I'm
very pleased about the unity we're
seeing and continuing to see across the
United Kingdom we need to do all we can
to support Ukraine and we need to act as
quickly as possible and I'm familiar
with the vagaries of the government
machine after spending 10 years in
various different government departments
so I do all I can to support my right
honorable friend the foreign secretary
and his efforts to make sure that things
happen as quickly as possible but we
also need to not forget the broader
arguments
freedom and democracy
are the lifeblood are the lifeblood of
our society and other free societies
around the world and we need to be
prepared to do what we can to defend
them now because it's before it's too
late
the fact is
that being tough
is what will bring us peace and that is
what we need to do yeah yeah
I'd also like to welcome our friends
from the United States of America from
Washington you're most Welcome to our
proceedings today Liam Byrne thank you
very much um Deputy speaker and it's a
great privilege actually to follow what
was an excellent speech from the right
honorable lady and indeed the rightful
member um for Oxbridge as well as the
two uh front benches
um there are sort of three things that I
wanted to add to this debate this
afternoon well first about the
importance of how we break uh the
balance of force that we see arranged on
the ground second how we now choke the
oligarchs of War who are helping Supply
uh Putin's war machine
um and third there is some more that we
need to say about how we commence the
pursuit for justice because I was a
little unhappy actually to hear the
foreign secretary who is just exiting
his place
um not Row in behind the vice president
of the United States and say that our
government too had arrived at the
conclusion that Russia was committing
crimes against humanity one does have to
ask how much more evidence do they
really need
but let me just start with first things
first which is uh the call that we heard
loud and clear from two former Prime
Ministers today which is about the need
to supply what Ukraine needs now
the truth is that both sides of this
conflict are going to find it difficult
to summon together the four to five
hundred thousand troops that are going
to be necessary to make a breakthrough
one-wheel deal
and so the challenge that may well lie
ahead is that Ukraine suffers this
pattern that we have today which is more
and more troops being thrown into
infantry attacks under artillery fire in
the east of the country
with endless missile strikes on
population centers that is a grinding
terrible waste of life and so I think
we've got to LeapFrog out of this bad
habit that we've gotten into the first
we say no and then we say yes
and there is this extended time period
between the saying no and then the
saying yes so on air defense we said no
to Patriot missiles until it was that we
said yes on tanks we said no until
months and months later we said yes now
can we please just Short Circuit the
process of sending in the f-16s as fast
as possible with trained pilots it's
great to hear that we are training
Pilots but what we saw last week at the
Munich Security Council uh conference
was a clear consensus between Democrats
and Republicans alike sending a very
clear message to the president of the
United States that they thought that it
was time
the fast Jets were sent to support our
allies in Ukraine we heard directly from
president zielinski just a few yards
from here the Wings of Freedom are
needed today so let's jump out of the no
and get to yes as fast as possible
of course Very quickly
we gave 14 Challenger tanks Challenger
twos to Ukraine they are very capable
tanks but in and of themselves they will
not change the whole course of the wall
but what they did do was help to unlock
the delivery of hundreds of leopards
what the ukrainians really want are migs
that they're familiar with using in
f-16s but by the same argument if we
gave one Squadron of older typhoons that
then unlocked hundreds of migs and f-16s
it would be worth doing wouldn't it
personally I think yes but my key point
I suppose to the front bench on the
treasury benches is please can we
short-circuit the time that it takes to
get from no to yes we've gone through
this Loop there's Doom loop at least
twice before let's short-circuit the
nonsense now and crack on with it and so
I think the message from to the treasury
benches is they will find cross-party
consensus on this question please just
put the decision on the dispatch box in
front of them we've heard last week from
the um the head of the Ukrainian Air
Force that these fast jets are needed
now in order to change the balance of
power on the battlefield but also to
protect the population centers from
Iranian drones as well as Russian cruise
missiles and so every single day that we
do not take this decision is a day when
Putin is allowed to continue reigning
Terror down not just on the troops of
the Brave Ukrainian Armed Forces but on
the civilians of Ukraine he is using
this capability now to perpetrate war
crimes and we have a moral
responsibility in this country to damn
well stop him
second Mr Deputy speaker we have got to
move harder and faster to choke to death
the oligarchs of War starting with the
dogs of war at the head of the Wagner
group
ly we were too slow to implement the
sanctions that we have I'm glad that
this house passed with a cross-party
consent uh the measures that we took to
basically allow us to cut and paste the
EU sanctions regime with a little bit of
the American regime to get that into
place it was a shame that it took the
war in Ukraine to actually move a little
bit further ahead on some of the
anti-kleptocracy laws that we have now
but here we are all progress is good
however Mr Deputy speaker there is clear
evidence that sanctions are being widely
evaded by
um goods and oil being exported to India
and to China being re-badged and then
re-exported from there and so given that
we have an office for financial
sanctions implementation in the treasury
that thinks it's okay to issue sanction
waivers to pregosin and his lawyers can
I urge the treasury benches to get a lot
tougher together with the Americans if
necessary in actually clamping down on
this export and re-export business
because it is supplying dollars right
now that are buying weapons to support
Putin
the symbol however of a different order
of things has got to be a radically
different approach to taking on the
Wagner group we know that today the
Wagner group is recruiting from prisons
they're recruiting from all over they
are mobilizing forces on the Eastern
front in Ukraine frankly they have
opened a second front against democracy
in Russia as well they are active in at
least five countries and they have
business interests in at least another
15 countries they are short-circuiting
the sanctions regime by trading in oil
trading in manganese in gold in uranium
you name it so it is a matter of concern
to this house
that we are woefully behind the
sanctions regime that the United States
and the Europeans have put in place to
suffocate pregosin and his forces
of course I thank my right honorable
friend and he's making an excellent
speech in terms of the Wagner group
would he agree with me that we also need
to try to rein in the growing influence
of the wagon group within Africa there
are many nations across the globe
wherein the Wagner group is making more
and more of an impact in eroding
democracy so it's about time that our
government working with allies
tried to clamp that down
what my friend is is absolutely right
and the right little lady talked about
the need for a Global Alliance to defend
democracy well that Global Alliance has
got to extend to Africa and the fact
that there are now five countries where
the Wagner group is active the fact that
they are poised to make something of a
breakthrough in the Sahel uh after the
French evacuation from Mali is a matter
that should concern us frankly we should
be getting a lot tougher on them and
that should start with a much more
comprehensive sanctions regime so can I
urge the minister who is winding up to
tell us that they will be replicating
the United States sanction regime on 21
different individuals who are associated
with the Wagner group and 16 different
corporate entities that is three times
more sanctions than we have against
individuals or businesses associated
with progozi let's go further we have
had now on the 23rd of January a very
clear pronouncement from our allies in
the United States that they have
declared the Wagner group to be a
prescribed organization because it is
patently a transnational criminal
organization yet when the minister who
is not in his place came before the
Foreign Affairs Committee just a couple
of weeks ago and Mr Speaker we were
grateful he was there because the truth
is that for some time the foreign office
and the ministry of Defense hadn't
couldn't quite decide who was the
minister responsible for taking on the
Wagner group and anyway in due course
the machine did its job and the poor
Minister was summoned before us he was
not able to answer when the Wagner group
was going to be sanctioned indeed he
extracted himself from the line of
questioning by saying that of course it
wasn't his job it was a matter for the
home office so joined up government at
its very best uh Mr Deputy speaker well
what we've got at the moment is not good
enough we need a clear plan a clear
timetable a clear commitment from the
minister today that the way Magna group
will be sanctioned here just as it is in
the United States of America we need a
clear commitment that the number of
individuals who have been sanctioned by
the Americans will be the same
individuals who has been sanctioned here
we need a clear commitment that the
individuals the European Union is
sanctioned will be individuals that are
sanctioned here as well and then finally
while we're at it could we now end the
Scandal that the treasury itself is
licensing sanction waivers for Russian
Warlords to fly lawyers from London to
Saint Petersburg to sum up a case to
prosecute to sue journalists like Elliot
Higgins in English courts what a
complete Scandal and then just to tap it
all last week Elliot Higgins is told
that he's the security risk and so he
can't be allowed to go to cinema
showings of the new film about the brave
Mr navalny what Have We Become Mr Deputy
speaker where we are licensing English
lawyers to sue English journalists in
English court it's not good enough it's
an outrage and it needs to stop and we
need to send a clear signal from this
house this afternoon that it ends now
while he's at it he might actually
consider paying Mr Elliott Higgins legal
bills I'm told that prego's in surprise
surprise this will surprise the house Mr
pregosian has not paid his legal bills
about 116 000 pounds but poor Mr Elliott
Higgins has he's had to cough up about
70 000 pounds so maybe the government
benches could do a little whip round for
Mr Higgins and Supply an apology to him
and bellingcat
um at the end of this debate so
we have got to make sure that the weapon
supplies are in place we have got to
make sure that the sanctions regime is
far more uh far more effective than it
is today and the third piece of the
puzzle has got to be we have got to
commence the search for justice it is
excellent that the United Kingdom has
come together with its allies to ensure
that there are prosecutions for war
crimes but I think many of us in this
house will want to see prosecutions for
the crime of aggression as well the
abuse
that has been laid out has been
appalling murder torture rape
deportation executions electrocutions
the crimes of Bucca the sexual assault
of a four-year-old child was reported to
the United Nations last week that is why
all of us in this house today
should welcome the statement by the Vice
President of the United States last week
that the U.S has formally determined
that Russia has committed crimes against
humanity
we should meet the same declaration
ourselves we should do it
quickly and I hope we will hear a game
plan for just that from the minister at
the end of the debate thank you
Mr Deputy speaker speaking of someone
that has given evidence in war crimes
trials five of them
the thing that really horrified me
was the only we only got a very small
percentage
of the people that carried out these
crimes and I'm talking about genocide
and war against uh war against humanity
a very small percentage so small it's
almost impossible to measure and so if
we're going to do this properly we've
got to put a heck of a lot of effort
into having war crimes trials you know
almost more than afternoon you know the
Nuremberg trials Etc
the whole of this house is grateful to
the work of the Gallant an honorable
member because we know that more people
were prosecuted because of the work that
he did than would have otherwise been
the case and he is absolutely right to
say what he has says it was 80 years ago
that the Free World came together to
ensure the prosecution of the guilty at
Nuremberg and the charge the table of
crimes that was presented was very clear
it was crimes against humanity and we
should remind ourselves in this house
exactly what that table of crimes
entails murder extermination
enslavement deportation
persecution on political racial and
religious grounds those are precisely
the crimes that President Putin has
committed in Ukraine and we must make
sure that just as we did in Nuremberg
the Free World comes together once more
to hold him as well as his henchmen to
account thank you very much so Julian
Lewis thank you Mr Deputy speaker and it
is
a matter of
great satisfaction that we have American
visitors present today to witness the
absolute Unity of outlook on both sides
of this chamber
it can never be stressed too often that
there are three concepts that lie at the
heart of defense and security
they are deterrence containment and the
unpredictability of future conflicts to
give an example of the last one has only
to look at the exchange between
my right honorable friend the member for
Uxbridge and former prime minister and
myself on the day of the invasion when I
asked him and I quote if this appears
likely Ukraine gets overwhelmed will we
offer to give Sanctuary to a government
in Exile pending Ukraine's future
freedom and he replied quite sensibly
one of the points I made he made to
president zielinski this morning was
that it might be necessary for him to
find a safe place for him and his
cabinet to go and I was quite sensible
in asking that question and my right
honorable friend was quite sensible in
giving that answer because let's be
frank not many people thought at least
not many people outside the cabinet and
government of Ukraine thought that
Ukraine had much chance of resisting
what appeared to be and indeed was a
massive albeit ill-conceived Onslaught
against numerically far smaller forces
now I said there are three concepts that
is an example of the unpredictability of
future warfare and therefore I would
just like to remind amateur strategists
such as myself in all parties that just
as we were not prepared for the
successful resistance of Ukraine we
shouldn't now become too complacent that
Ukraine cannot possibly be defeated we
could wake up tomorrow to find there had
been some terrific unexpected Russian
breakthrough and that the whole
strategic situation had changed
completely and that is why the appeals
that are being made so strongly from
both sides of the house that we must to
coin someone coining someone else
coining a phrase give them the tools to
finish the job
and in terms of deterrence well it can
be argue deterrence failed but then why
did Terrence fail in terms of Russia
invading Ukraine I'm sorry to share this
uh with friends from across the Atlantic
but I feel that one reason deterrence
failed in that context was the fact that
the invasion of Ukraine by Russia came
almost six months to the day from the
catastrophic and bungled exit from
Afghanistan by NATO I'm not saying that
that planted the seed in Putin's mind to
do what he did but it certainly may well
have affected the timing of him doing
something that he had almost certainly
wanted to do for a very long time
and so we have to bear in mind what sort
of signals we were sending and the
answer is we were sending signals of
weakness and when you send signals of
weakness to an authoritarian which is
the the rather mild term used these days
for what most of us from another era
would call the totalitarian type of of
government you ought to know what to
expect their behavior to be
so I've talked about the
unpredictability I've talked about the
limitations of deterrence
albeit that there's one element of
deterrence because it is more certain
what the results will be if you dare to
put it to the test namely nuclear
deterrence that is nevertheless
something that everyone has to consider
in every scenario no matter what sort of
terrible fighting and atrocious Behavior
may go on below the level of the nuclear
threshold so let's talk a little bit
however about containment
and containment is what you have to do
when you are faced with a deeply hostile
opponent it is no good talking about
battling for Mutual understanding the
trouble is you can have mutual
understanding where one person
understands that the other person is a
Democrat and the Democrat understands
that the other person is a totalitarian
dictator that is not a recipe for peace
it is actually a sound
portrayal of a situation where unless
the Democrats chose the dictator that he
cannot get his own way by Force of Arms
the dictator will try to get his own way
by Force of Arms
I've got two other topics I want to
touch on very briefly in this
contribution
one is to draw attention to an important
analysis that appeared
on a website called desk ruse on the
30th of December
2021 which was just two months before
The Invasion and it was by an old friend
of mine I've known her for the best part
of 40 years a brilliant French historian
and former sovietologist
called Dr Francoise Tom
and she Drew attention to two draft text
treaties which had been unveiled by the
Russian foreign Ministry on the 17th of
December 2021 one being a treaty between
the United States and the Russian
Federation on security guarantees and
the other being an agreement on measures
to ensure the security of the Russian
Federation and the member states of the
North Atlantic Treaty Organization
and what was made absolutely clear
was that these were take it or leave it
offers and they uh were encapsulated by
the deputy foreign minister grushko who
said and I quote the Europeans must also
think about whether they want to avoid
making their continent the scene of a
military confrontation they have a
choice either they take seriously what
is put on the table or they face a
military technical alternative that's
War to the rest of us this is a deputy
foreign minister stating in terms that
unless European states do what Russia
wants then they can expect to be
embroiled in armed conflict a former
deputy Minister of Defense Andre
catapauloff Duma defense committee
said as follows are Partners meaning our
partners in the west must understand
that the longer they drag out the
examination of our proposals and the
adoption of real measures to create
these guarantees the greater the
likelihood that they will suffer a
pre-emptive strike
now what was in these draft treaties
I'll just give you one example article
four states in part that and I quote the
Russian Federation are all participants
which were as of 27th May 1997 member
states of the North Atlantic Treaty
Organization shall not deploy their
armed forces and armaments on the
territory of any other European state in
addition to the forces stationed on that
territory as of 27th of May 1997. what's
the significance of 1997 well it's this
Madam Deputy speaker it was only after
1997 that 14 of the present 30 members
of NATO joined the alliance
so starting in 1999 you had the Czech
Republic you had Hungary and you had
Poland and then you had
almost a dozen more and so what the
Russians were basically saying is unless
America agrees to withdraw its support
from all these newly freed democracies
and unless all NATO countries agree to
withdraw their armed forces from all
those NATO member countries they can
expect to find themselves in an armed
conflict with Russia and the trouble is
that statements of this sort do not get
reported in the west as clearly as they
should be if at all they are generally
kept in as it were the specialized
centers and the highly
learned brains of people like Dr
Francoise Tom
and I'm basically saying that there are
three outcomes when you get into a
situation like this the first is you can
capitulate
the second is open Warfare
and the third is containment otherwise
known in the old days as cold war and I
really resent it when people say oh you
don't want to go back to the Cold War
well if the alternatives are
capitulation or open Warfare then the
cold war is the very best you can do in
staring down an aggressor and and I end
Madam Deputy speaker where I began with
an intervention which is just to draw
attention to the state of the UK's
defense budget notwithstanding the
considerable injection of uh cash which
was made under the previous prime
minister my right honorable friend for
axbridge
even that only brought our percentage of
Defense expenditure up from about 2.1
percent of GDP to 2.3 percent
and in uh uh a few years earlier in
around 2015 there was an a change in the
accounting methods for calculating what
our expenditure on defense was for
purposes of of GDP and that was not an
illegitimate change it just led to us
including certain items which NATO count
towards defense expenditure which we had
not previously done
if it hadn't been for that change in
accounting
our expenditure on defense would not
have been at 2.1 percent which is what
it was before my right honorable friends
cash injection it would have been at 1.8
and his cash injection would have taken
it up to 2.1 now under the old system of
accounting in the mid-1990s we were
still spending three percent of GDP on
defense at the height of the Cold War in
the mid-1980s as I've said time and
again to this house we regularly and
consistently spent under the old system
of accounting between four and a half
and five percent of GDP on defense we
hear talk of arguments between the
defense Ministry and the treasury on
whether or not some extra billions will
be made available
we all recognize that if Ukraine
succeeds in defeating this aggression
they're doing it for their own benefit
but they will benefit the whole of the
western world because it means that the
odds of us ever having to engage in that
sort of fighting ourselves against the
regime of this sort in Russia will be
massively reduced ask yourself Madam
Deputy speaker what we would do if we
found ourselves against our will
forced into a conflict of that sort
immediately the amount that we had to
spend on defense would shoot up not to
three percent but probably to something
like 10 or 15 percent of just about
every single scrap of effort financially
economically and industrially that this
country could possibly do because that
is what always happens if you find
yourself in a war not to mention all the
costs in human life and treasure and
misery and therefore this should be seen
as an investment we are investing if we
increase our defense budget in the
freedom of Ukraine and we are investing
in the freedom and the Peace of the
whole of the western world
uh Judith Cummins thank you madam Deputy
speaker and it's a pleasure to follow on
from The Honorable member opposite from
New Forest East and to hear such Unity
across this house on this issue a year
on this war will leave lasting imprints
on every Ukrainian and indeed on world
history this time and this Milestone
will mean something different to every
person affected by it and here today we
know that this moment shows that history
will stand on the side of the Ukrainian
people
International Security and the stability
of the world order was threatened when
Russian Federation forces began their
Invasion on the 24th of February 2022.
whilst the future appeared uncertain
through the Indescribable bravery and
resilience of the Ukrainian people its
military forces and indeed its
government Ukraine has exercised its
power and turn what could have been a
brief moment in time into an historical
struggle for freedom
and I've spoken before in this place
about the human impact of this war and
in December I visited leviv
Kiev and the region of Harkey with the
right honorable member for chingford and
Woodford Woodford green we joined the
charity Siobhan's trust whose
humanitarian Aid reflects our core
British values their work in feeding
over 4 000 displaced ukrainians every
day is to be both admired and applauded
and everywhere we went the real power of
the Ukrainian people was clear to see
Putin's forces had inflicted horrific
damage in damage on their towns cities
and Villages I saw blocks of flats
people's homes gutted by missile attacks
in Hakeem
schools destroyed in satini and Hermes
peppered with shrapnel in ruska lozava
and one soldier told me about the horror
of removing the dead bodies from bombed
out buildings mostly homes
he showed me a photograph of a dead
little boy laid out on a bench and he
told me that the father had clung onto
him with desperation and he had to be
pulled from his son and in typical
Ukrainian understatement he said it's
hard
and he told me of his men who found it
too hard and had gone home and shot
themselves he worried for his men men
who urgently needed help in dealing with
the impact of stress while still serving
on the front line
but despite the inhumanity of war the
Ukrainian people live with dignity and
compassion as they fight on Bravely
towards victory
and I met with businesses who were
working to keep Ukraine's economy
functioning in the most challenging of
circumstances under bombing and a
planned power Cuts businesses such as
the Potato Factory which despite War has
kept its investments in Ukraine
this is their contribution to the war
effort to keep the economy going to
provide food for the nation jobs for
workers and to pay taxes to fund
Ukraine's war efforts these people and
businesses defy Putin's best effort to
crush the free spirits of Ukraine
they are essential to success in this
war and when the time comes they will
continue to support Ukraine as it
flourishes again as a peaceful and
independent state and of course we must
continue to support Ukraine by providing
it with the necessary military
capabilities
but equally we must support the recovery
effort and I praise the upcoming Ukraine
recovery conference jointly hosted by
the UK government and Ukraine because no
matter when this war ends we must begin
laying the foundations for structural
and economic recovery now
and to close Madam Deputy speaker
everywhere
myself my rights honorable friend
went
in Ukraine the same message was
delivered to us do not forget us yeah
Ukraine can claim astonishing victories
already for more war May well continue
but Ukraine has achieved what many once
believed was impossible
for the last year it's firmly withstood
a hostile invading Force intent on
bringing democracy to its knees history
is being Rewritten history is being
written by Ukraine Freedom will win
Slava Ukraine
uh Richard Ford thank you madam Deputy
speaker and it is an honor to follow
both the the right honorable member for
New Forest East and The Honorable member
for Bradford South um who really did
bring this back down to uh the
individual experience of a terrible War
um so so I'm grateful and I'm going to
spend the next few minutes arguing that
we should
provide for war and prepare for peace
that is we in the UK should increase
seriously our industrial production for
defense for Ukraine and for our own
while also isolating Russia and seizing
diplomatic opportunities when they arise
so you can characterize it as better
preparation for war and George or
I would like also to identify a couple
of events from the last century or so
that can shine a light on the situation
that Ukraine finds itself facing and
that Ukraine's Partners find ourselves
facing
they are the 1915 shell crisis in
Britain on the one hand in the 1999
withdrawal of Yugoslav security forces
from Kosovo on the other
first let's recall NATO's War
let's recall NATO's role in this war
in Russian propaganda right now Moscow
is characterizing this as NATO's War
the Kremlin suggests that the government
in Kiev is a puppet and that NATO is
pulling the strings
but it couldn't be further from the
truth the provision of Arms by Ukraine's
Partners such as the UK is often a
reactive response to requests for
support
I'd like to pay
to the British government and credit to
the Secretary of State for defense and
the ministry of defense for repeatedly
stating that this is Ukraine's war that
Ukraine is our close partner and that we
are supplying Ukraine with equipment and
support but the contrary to Russian
propaganda this is not NATO's war and
that there is no sense in which NATO is
threatening Russia
but nor are we in the business of
subcontracting policy to the government
in Kiev we should not be answering each
and every request on this reactive basis
there are times when we should be
supplying equipment proactively
for example the British government
announced that it would be supplying
Warrior infantry fighting Vehicles when
asked though the liberal Democrats have
been calling for this in the months
prior to that announcement but we should
anticipate requests by Ukraine rather
than waiting for them to land
but the right honorable member for
Birmingham Hodge Hill suggested that
there's this pattern of saying no
until we say yes
but then I would say rightly the UK is
stepping up its provision at a time when
we know that our allies
have moved or are ready to move on that
point I would be great just try and
round out the cross-party consensus that
I think is emerging with the honorable
member
um agree that we should be doing
everything we can to send fast Jets to
Ukraine
I I would suggest to the right honorable
member
um that if we are to send fast Jets to
Ukraine it is going to be a symbolic
gesture because what we heard from uh
the the minister when we visited Keith
uh he and I last September was that
Minister uh reznikov was asking for
Gripen aircraft as as we've heard from
uh from uh in this chamber today so if
we have to do so it's not because we've
got the capability that is particularly
useful to Ukraine it's because it'll be
a symbolic first mover gesture that
others can follow
I think that the another example of this
is is clearly the provision of main
battle tanks once we knew that other
countries were at least considering or
almost ready to provide main battle
tanks
but we do have to have greater
anticipation of what demand arrives
before it takes for zelensky to to visit
us and to make those requests
we've heard that Ukrainian forces are
firing up to 5000 artillery rounds per
day Ukraine's Partners will struggle to
maintain Supply at that level
from our existing stockpiles and we're
going to need to procure artillery
rounds quickly
just in time acquisition might play well
on spreadsheets but it does not played
well in relation to our inventories
there are times when matters of Supply
really are crucial
Britain found itself short of high
explosive brands in 1915.
Lloyd George was appointed the inaugural
Minister for Munitions a position that
when he became prime minister he gave to
his fellow liberal Winston Churchill who
became minister of human for Munitions
in 1917.
the creation of a Ministry for Munitions
indicate just how serious Britain was in
Prosecuting the war
I'm Not For a Moment suggesting that we
need today to to promote the uh the
minister for defense defense procurement
but we do need to coordinate the
purchase of Munitions with our allies
given that we are drawing on the same
Western suppliers in many instances and
we need to do it on an enduring basis
we see now that Russia is moving
increasingly towards a total war footing
where it's mobilizing increasingly the
resources of its society and of its
economy to the war effort
it may have sought to play Down the
so-called special military operation
last February but it's increasingly
having to recognize that what it's
created is followed the full-scale
invasion and the time will eventually
arrive for Ukrainian negotiation
it should come from a position of
strength for Ukraine
when the time comes for negotiation we
should be open to The Leverage that
Beijing will have with Moscow
that NATO Nations do not
to illustrate recall how the orders were
eventually given for the withdrawal of
Yugoslav security forces from Kosovo
Yugoslavia conceded when it realized
that it was isolated
the NATO bombing of Yugoslavia in the
spring and summer of 1999 NATO was
bombing military sites across Serbia and
Montenegro
in pursuit of the withdrawal of Yugoslav
Security Forces
follow ethnic cleansing that Yugoslav
Security Forces had perpetrated against
Kosovo albanians
but the NATO bombing campaign had gone
on for more than 10 weeks there was no
sign that slobodian milosevic was
prepared to concede and withdraw
Yugoslav military and parliamentary
Personnel from Kosovo
the NATO enforcement actions seemed to
be stuck and NATO bombing sorties Were
Striking the same targets repeatedly
president Yeltsin played an important
role in persuading sloboding milosevic
to withdraw Yugoslav security forces
from Kosovo
as Boris yeltsin's Falcons Envoy Victor
chenamedin communicated to milosevic
that Belgrade could no longer depend on
diplomatic support from an ally
Chatham Adam was later to become a
dreadful Russian ambassador to Ukraine
and you know he's rightly very unpopular
in Ukraine but he was successful in
persuading milosevic that he had no Ally
to whom he could turn for support
milosevic chose to consent to the
withdrawal of Yugoslav Security Forces
only when he realized just how isolated
he was
so let's not just be too dismissive of
China's offer
before we know what it is
of course we should pay careful
attention to the speech that is coming
up by President XI on Friday it will
probably be full of platitudes it might
offer nothing except a ceasefire based
on the current possession by Russian
forces of Ukrainian land in which case
it would clearly be completely
unacceptable
but the current statements made by China
relate to the importance of sovereignty
and territorial integrity
and so we're not there yet but China may
have a role to play in pressuring Russia
into its eventual withdrawal from
Ukraine
we would have that discussion not being
naive about China's motives
Russia and China have been adversaries
to each other so it might suit China to
have Russia and the West
depleting their weapons stockpiles in a
conflict taking place far away from the
Asian indo-pacific
but notice it suit China to have the
West threatening consequences against
China as as blinken warned would result
from the supply of Arms by China to
Russia
Russian people need to know that this is
Russia's War it's not NATO's war and nor
is it China's War
we in the UK do need to prepare UK
defense just now like this war is our
own
we must Supply Ukraine so that it can
capture more of its territory before it
seeks to enter into a ceasefire
and then at that point we should be open
to recognizing the value that Russia's
Partners can have in persuading Putin to
pull back
uh Nadia with him
thank you madam Deputy speaker and it's
it's a pleasure to follow on from the
member for Tiverton and hollerton and
indeed members from across the house
I speak as a socialist an
Anti-Imperialist and as someone who
feels disgust at the thought of war and
it's not despite these values that I
support the Ukrainian resistance it's
because of them to me socialism means
self-determination for ordinary working
people not seeding power to tyrants
seeking to oppress them
anti-imperialism means opposing all
states that seek to extend their power
by dominating others regardless of what
flag they fly
it's impossible to talk about the war in
Ukraine without addressing the bloody
history of Russian imperialism it's a
history that our friends across Eastern
and Northern Europe don't need to be
reminded of they know that that what's
at stake is not just lines on a map and
whose flag flies above a town hall no a
nation that survived the holodomor
understands the invader's aims the
Erasure of a people the eradication of
its culture and the destruction of its
democracy
it's easy to debate geopolitics from the
comfort of London but the stakes feel
very different when you hear directly
from someone sleeping in a bomb shelter
and when I speak to workers to trade
unionists in Ukraine or to refugees
hoping to see their home again their
message is clear and heartfelt don't
abandon us
Madam Secretary speaker it would not be
an anti-warf stance to turn our backs on
Ukraine it would be sending a message to
despots around the globe that war crimes
pay it would be accepting a global order
based not on international law and
respect for sovereignty but on torture
murder and nuclear threats
the Ukrainian resistance isn't asking us
for thoughts and prayers solidarity
means helping Ukraine defend itself and
we can and we must do more over a
thousand military vehicles were sold off
by the ministry of defense last year so
I asked Madame Deputy speaker why aren't
we donating them to Ukraine instead
but of course Putin doesn't just fight
with tanks and missiles he fights with
disinformation and manipulation flooding
the internet with propaganda
discouraging Ukraine's allies is a key
part of his plan and we won't fall for
it
as the UK struggles with the painful
cost of living crisis Putin wants us to
blame support for Ukraine but while
soaring energy bills are forcing workers
into food banks energy Giants are
popping champagne bottles celebrating
their record profits instead of giving
up on solidarity we must tax those who
profit from war and misery
poverty we must think about Ukraine too
after a year of Relentless attack the
country is devastated and Ordinary
People are playing the price
its economy contracted by a third last
year inflation stands at 26 and more
than a quarter of people are unemployed
it will take years for the nation to
heal and rebuild
and when Russian troops are finally
pushed out our solidarity can't end it's
not enough to freeze Ukraine's debt it
must be canceled
let's close loopholes in our sanctions
regime and liquidate seized assets to
fund reconstruction
Madam Deputy speaker future economic
support can't come with conditions of
brutal austerity either the
International Community must come
together to support the rebuilding of
Ukraine's Public Services the creation
of green jobs and the strengthening of
its democracy
decisions about the Reconstruction
process can't be made by oligarchs and
foreign companies seeking to profit from
it but by the Ukrainian people
themselves with input from trade unions
and Civil Society
and meanwhile we must accept all
refugees seeking safety from the war
ensuring access to decent housing and
the services they need
all ukrainians in the UK today I say
you're always welcome here and to call
this country your home
but I know that's not what many of you
want
so I hope and sincerely believe that
soon you will be able to return to a
free and peaceful Ukraine slave
Jim Shannon thank you speaker can I say
what a pleasure it is to speak in this
to be able to make a contribution I want
to focus on other Khan and some of the
speeches have indeed all the species of
the med contributions have referred to
the war but I want to maybe be more
specific in what I'm going to speak to
my stance and and on McClean is well
known in this chamber has been
consistent as is everybody else's as
well I believe we do need to know more
to support our allies and Ukraine and I
said this before the visitor president
zelansky who by his very nature uh
inspires everyone who he meets and does
give the leadership a decree and needs
Russia's aggression must be halted not
simply for the lives destroyed in
Ukraine but the but for the message that
needs to be and must be sent
my heart aches as I watch the news and
see lives torn apart in Ukraine and as I
look into the eyes of some of the
refugees who have come from Ukraine to
Northern Ireland uh and and the hurt
that they have the eyes tell much Madam
Deputy speaker when it comes to
conveying the issues and how people feel
and I remember when I had their occasion
through the appg for federal religious
belief to go to Poland to see some of
the
um the conditions that Paul were
offering and they never had to tell you
anything about what they've been through
you just looked at them and their eyes
told me everything of the pain the
suffering and the memories that they had
and the Northern Ireland we've been very
pleased to have taken many of those
refugees
but they've left their loved ones in
their homes left behind and as they
wonder will they ever be able to go home
and what their that home will now look
like and we'll see the bombs that the
Russia and their destruction that has
carried this house in our government uh
must perhaps with others step up and do
more Russia's aggression as I said to
the minister in an intervention the
beginning I referred to the systematic
um abuse by Russian soldiers given the
authority at the highest level of
government of generals write down the
rip the sexual abuse of women and girls
some as young as four some as old as 83
years old so that gives you an idea
about the systematic cruelty of the
Russian soldiers and of the abuse that
they carry out
I'd also like to draw attention of
account to the violations of freedom of
religion or belief and that's what I
want to speak to in in this short time
that I that I address the house as
Russia's invasion of Ukraine enters its
second year it's important to note that
the attacks on religious freedom and
other human rights are ask anything
reports show that the Russian military
has destroyed has damaged or loaded at
least 494 religious buildings
theological institutions and sacred
sites and Ukraine since the start of the
invasion just last year according to
International humanitarian law on
justifiable attacks against religious
sites constitute war crimes as they are
and we all recognize that in this place
such attacks are happening in tandem
with attaching pastures and religious
leaders in the region these attacks are
not only against the Ukrainian Orthodox
Believers and their churches but also
against evangelicals Evangelical prayer
houses too because there are many home
churches across Ukraine especially in
the east of the province as well as a
Catholic Jehovah's Witnesses Jewish and
Muslim sites
The Institute for Religious Freedom was
found at Russian forces have also
abducted Ukrainian pastors and tried to
enlist them as Russian spies and
propagandas Baptist Church have been
destroyed in the eastern part of Ukraine
they've been damaged by bombs as well
there's been a systematic destruction of
those properties Baptist pastors have
went missing over the last couple of
years and did over the last four to five
years some of them have never been fined
and we do question just exactly what has
happened to them
from February 24 to July 15 2022 The
Institute recorded 20 cases of a legal
imprisonment of Ukrainian religious
leaders accompanied by attentive rape by
mock executions by deprivation of water
of food and access toilets and threats
of violence against family members not
only the person of the church who leads
the church but the families as well
moreover it's not only ukrainians who
suffer at Russia's hands Russia's
religions leaders who voice opposition
to the war in Ukraine also fear for
their lives and I give I cooked one of
those cases and Moscow patriarch priest
Alexander debasket fled Russia in
January of this year just shortly after
the police from the FSB had opened a
criminal case against him
he had repeatedly preached against the
war in Ukraine everything related to my
anti-war position uh was recorded in a
moose thorough manner he told for Forum
18. this is just one of many cases where
religious leaders
um are targeted and suffer for speaking
the truth and I think in accord with
their conscience I want to um
put on on record my thanks to our
government to our ministers to the
former prime ministers who have both
spoken in this chamber and and their
strong stance on these issues I think
their leadership at that time inspired
uh not just the United Kingdom but the
rest of Neto and across the world to
stand strong with Ukraine and I thank
them for them
one thing is clear we cannot allow
Russian aggression and Putin to beat us
with this long waged warm War fatigue is
a real thing
um
and and I welcome President Biden's a
commitment today to another 500 million
pound I think it was uh in in military
aid on their own commitment from her own
prime minister her own government along
those lines as well but some of the
other European companies should step up
and match that as well I I think um it
was a um a member from Woodford green I
told us one time uh that he was in
Ukraine about a month ago and it was
saying that there are many many soldiers
who are suffering from PTSD the papers
referred to that a day so I think maybe
I would ask a minister if there is any
more that we can do for those soldiers
who are suffering from PTSD who have
maybe a war fatigue
um because it is a real thing another
attention rightly goes to Global
emergencies such as the earthquakes in
turkey and Syrian
by the same token we cannot allow
ourselves to be distracted from our
commitment to Ukraine and I trust that
the message today from this house is
clear we will not be deterred from
helping our allies we will continue to
stand against Putin and all the Badness
and evil and wickedness that he
represents and that is not all quiet on
this Western Front where the battle is
we will be using our voices in this
chamber our Munitions from our factories
and our voices to continue to reject the
invasion of our King
Ukrainian spirit that courage that
inspiration that they have given us all
across the world we will not be beaten
down we will not give in to this
dashboard Baron W speaker thank you uh
thank you madam Deputy speaker
the Grim reality is war in Europe is no
longer in our rear view mirror it is now
we are living in a bleak new chapter in
the history of Europe as Putin seeks to
destroy the sovereignty of our Ukrainian
friends and seeks to attack the
principles of democracy that the
rules-based world order is built on
as the UK Falls silent on Friday morning
for a national moment of reflection for
Ukraine we're reminded of the
devastating toll that this war has had
on the Ukrainian people
the tens of thousands of lives that have
been needlessly lost the families that
have been torn apart and displaced from
their homes with over a hundred thousand
of them now here in the UK
the women who have been raped and
violated
the children who have been stolen by
Russia
and the economic and social fabric of a
Nation left in tatters
there's the ongoing struggle for peace
it is their fight in Ukraine but it is
also our fight and yet despite all the
suffering and the horror that Ukraine
has endured the flame of Freedom Burns
Brighton Kiev just look at the
extraordinary resilience of the
Ukrainian people in the face of Russian
aggression that we've heard in speeches
from both sides of the house today
praising the skill bravery and fortitude
of the Ukrainian military to defend
their Homeland
and as we've heard from the former prime
minister
the incredible and inspiring leadership
of president zielinski
just under a fortnight ago members in
this house were privileged to hear from
president zielinski in his address to
Westminster Hall
his speech moved us all
and reminded us what is at stake
colleagues from across the house have
made some extraordinary contributions in
this debate and I'm just saddened that
there weren't more of us here to hear
what good speeches they have been
to have a debate where we have two
former Prime Ministers speak is good and
if I'm honest Madam Deputy speaker it is
not normal that those two individuals
might elicit cross-party support given
the events of the past year but there
has been I think in this debate an
extraordinary level of cross-party
consensus a Unity that goes across
political parties across Nations and
across our continents in our support for
Ukraine and our determination that Putin
must lose
that is a message that Putin hoped there
would never be false never be shared
because he hoped to fracture the West he
hoped to change what we had here from a
United position to one a division where
we turn against each other and that has
not happened at the giving way
thank you madam Deputy speaker I think
I'm the oldest person in this chamber no
no
by a long way
but I remember the Vietnam War
and the Americans
were forced to withdraw
from Vietnam by public pressure at home
largely
we haven't talked in this debate about
what's happening in Moscow and other
parts of Russia but it must be
horrendous with sixty thousand dead and
huge numbers of them returning with
post-traumatic stress disorder I'm sure
and actually we have got to put huge
effort
into getting through to the Russian
people
to convince them
that this war is actually not fair it's
not right and they should actually put
huge pressure on their own governments
their own government get rid of Putin I
actually saw sort this out withdraw and
then we in the end as the former prime
minister has suggested implied perhaps
you'll correct me we've also got to have
a Russia that works and is a decent
place for Russians to live because
Russian soldiers are just like our
soldiers
they're doing their Duty
and they don't really have much Choice
yeah yeah thank you I think the the uh
the only gentleman for that intervention
uh you are what you eat and that is true
of food as it is of media that you can
see and when we look to our uh to the
people of Russia
the media that they are able and allowed
to consume is one that tells a very
one-sided story Tells a Story Only from
the Putin mouthpiece in the Kremlin no
challenge no debates and so how we deal
with misinformation how we deal with the
deliberate calculation to deny the truth
from his own people is quite a challenge
and that is something that we must
address in terms of information
operations and those those parts of how
we tell a story one of the pieces that
the BBC World Service was so good at
that's something a purpose for them now
um man Deputy speaker in this debate we
have heard about the complacency that
the UK has had from Russian gas from the
former prime minister the member for
Northwest South West Norfolk who's
certainly not in her place at the moment
but we've also heard from both sides of
the house about how the Wagner group
should be listed as a terrorist
organization because they're not just a
sponsor of terrorism they are the
terrorism
and if we don't act now we will be
repeating the mistakes of the past
because as we have seen we are looking
in a rear view mirror to comment on what
has happened to look forwards we've seen
what the Wagner group has done in Syria
we're seeing what they're doing in
Ukraine and as my honorable friend from
Slough said in his intervention we can
see what they could potentially be doing
in Africa as well so let's hurry up and
make that decision
um man Gucci speaker Putin's criminal
invasion of Ukraine is appalling it's
brutal and unjust Putin displays
contempt for international institutions
humanitarian laws and the rules of
military conflict but above all Putin
has shown as callous disregard for human
life Ukrainian and Russian he treats
human life as nothing more than pawns to
satisfy his monstrous ambition and that
is why the leader of the opposition has
said clearly that Putin should stand
trial in The Hague for his crimes at a
special Tribunal
as we know Putin's aim is not simply to
take Ukraine we're facing a tyrant who
wants to use his War to redraw the map
of Europe he wants to destroy the unity
of the West and one year on as the
former prime minister of Oxbridge and
Southwest said there is still no sign
that any of Putin's strategic aims have
changed nor have they been achieved
but this war can only end in failure for
Putin it will he will fail because he's
miscalculated the incredible resolve of
the Ukrainian people to defend their
Homeland he will fail because he's
underestimated the strength of resolve
on these Shores and across the West to
support Ukraine for as long as it takes
to defeat Russia and he will fail
because the millions of voices defending
democracy will over time drown out the
hate and division of tyrants and
dictators
my mom's actually speaker
the government has had Labor's fullest
support on Brit or on Britain's military
help to Ukraine and as uh my honorable
friendly the opposition said on his
visit to Kiev only a few days ago for as
long as this as Putin continues to wage
of this criminal War the government will
continue to have Labor's fullest support
but as we head into the second year of
this conflict there are a number of
important questions I'd like to press
the minister on
thank my honorable friend for giving way
does he agree with me that rather than
the ministry of Defense selling off
1105 Vehicles last year are either two
authoritarian regimes or auctioning them
to private arms dealers that these
should be donated to Ukraine to support
their their um their resistance
I think normal friend for her
intervention
um I think it is um I think it is really
important that we look at military
disposals we look carefully at where
those are where that equipment goes but
what I would say is there has been good
support for the uh for Ukraine so far
but we'd like that support to go further
and that's indeed I think is the point
that she is trying to make at that point
uh there
um as my uh friend the uh foreign son of
foreign secretary said while 25 NATO
Nations have rebooted defense plans
since the start of the invasion the UK
government has yet to do so despite
labor arguing for ministers to reboot
defense plans since last March in next
month's review of the integrated review
and the spring budget the government
must take the opportunity to move on
from these ad hoc announcements and set
out a more systematic support approach
for Ukraine so when the master gets to
his feet can he confirm when the minute
when the government will set out a full
2023 action plan for military economic
and diplomatic support to help give
Ukraine confidence in a sustained stream
of future supplies as labor has
consistently argued for and can he also
say whether now is still the right time
as He suggests for the government to
proceed with cuts to our Armed Forces
before the integrated review reports
and can the minister also reflect on
calls from both sides of this house to
restrict the Wagner group
am I right on my friend from Birmingham
Hodge Hill set it out very clearly when
he set the objective of suffocating the
Wagner group and closing the sanctions
loopholes
there is cross-party support for that
and I encourage the minister to get on
with it the magic speaker I want to
briefly turn to stockpiles because it's
been raised by members from both sides
of the house
on this side we welcome the 2.3 billion
the government has allocated to Ukraine
last year and this year and the 560
million to fill some of the empty
stockpiles but we need to be clear it's
not enough there is an immediate need to
replenish our own stockpiles which have
been depleted in supporting Ukraine and
to date the government has acted too
slowly to replenish them members in
Slough Angus and New Forest East have
made that point quite clearly in this
debate there is now a growing need to
set out a clear stockpile strategy to
sustain support for Ukraine and re-arm
Britain in the long term that's a clear
strategy working with industry allowing
them to invest with a certainty of what
can come out of it because we need to be
certain to our friends in Ukraine that
when we make a pledge that we will
support them that we have the industrial
capability to honor that promise
something that has been said on both
sides of the house
the in-law anti-tank missile for example
which has been vital to Ukraine took 287
days since the latest Invasion before
the mod got its act together and signed
a new contract but the First new end law
won't come off the production line until
2024. we need to shift parts of our
defense industry and the initial defense
procurement to an urgent operational
footing both to support Ukraine and to
rebuild UK stocks for any future
conflict so can the minister set out how
long it will take our armed forces and
our industry Partners to replenish UK
stockpiles to ensure we can defend our
own Shores while honoring our
commitments to Ukraine and NATO and if
the UK is to be the first nation to send
long-range missiles to Ukraine as the
Prime Minister stated in Munich then by
what date will they be sent and assuming
they are the Storm Shadow missiles how
will they be replaced and what is the
plan
and what plans is this department making
to urgently ramp up our own industry so
we're left better equipped to deal with
future conflicts the government has far
too often raided the stockpile to make
efficient savings efficiency savings
that is a mistake that has come home to
uh Roost now and we cannot repeat that
again
Deputy speaker Russia is not a spent
Force
which damage Ukraine has inflicted on
its military
the spring offensive that is now perhaps
only days and weeks away we'll see
Russia massively expand its war effort
it's conscripting more people and
although it's sending them into a
bloodbath that few of them will survive
against high-end Western Weaponry this
war could continue for a very long time
NATO Secretary General has said only
last week that we are seeing the start
of a new Russian offensive already so in
order to support Kiev with this new
spring offensive can the minister update
the house whether the UK is on track to
send the 14 Challenger 2 tanks to
Ukraine and how they will be supported
in field
I think it would be much easier for the
minister if he were just able to agree
to set out a long-term plan rather than
ad hoc announcements
I want to pay tribute to all those
people across the United Kingdom who
have welcomed Ukrainian refugees into
their homes who are fundraised for them
who have gone the extra mile to deliver
supplies and Aid to our friends in UK
themselves this has been a huge
undertaking and I also want to thank the
officials in the home office who have
helped facilitate the homes for Ukraine
scheme as well as colleagues in the
department for leveling up but we need
to recognize there are holes in those
schemes now that need to be filled
that is not a part-time critique that is
just making something work properly we
do need that to be looked at properly to
make sure that if this war continues as
I fear it may do the support we can
offer those people who have fled War can
be consistent and long lasting as well
Madam Deputy speaker the invasion of
Ukraine did not start a year ago
it started nine years ago
and we must learn the lessons from how
we were complacent at that time How the
West Was sleeping
how we gave a a
dictator and a tyrant in the Kremlin a
effectively the green light by not
taking stronger action
the Ukraine the UK must be prepared to
support Ukraine for the long term
renewing our resolve in confronting
Russian threats pursuing Putin's war
crimes and standing with Ukraine should
there be a change of government at the
next general election it is important to
say there will be no change in Britain's
position of support for Ukraine
Amanda speaker never again is a phrase
said too often in this house but never
again is now
we must rise to the same Heights as our
Ukrainian friends to ensure that Putin
loses and Ukraine wins thank you
thank you madam Deputy speaker
um Madame Deputy speaker we've had a
serious somber but spirited debate today
as befits the subject at hand and there
have been many powerful speeches
including from two former Prime
Ministers no less and I will touch on a
number of them in in due course but let
me Begin by noting a clear and
overriding a message message that
emerges from our deliberations and that
is the solidarity from all sides of this
house for our Ukrainian friends their
sheer bloody-minded Defiance in the face
of unprovoked and brutal aggression has
moved and inspired us all
and it is indeed unprovoked and brutal
aggression
history is littered with examples of
conflicts where in truth it's far from
Clear which side has the better claim to
the moral High Ground the issues are
murky facts are contested arguments cut
both ways
this is not such a conflict
Putin's actions invading a sovereign
country at peace with its neighbors and
which pose no threat are self-evidently
morally bankrupt
they lack even a shred of justification
indeed Putin's pretext namely that the
Jewish Ukrainian president was somehow a
fascist is as Preposterous as it is
desperate
no The kremlin's Invasion is depraved
cruel unnecessary and illegal it is a
war of choice that has brought needless
death and destruction it has taken
thousands of lives and wrecked countless
more and it has brought appalling
suffering to innocent people including
campus children the world knows it
Ukraine knows it Vladimir Putin knows it
Deputy speaker this debate has a special
poignancy coming as it does so close to
the one-year point from The full-scale
Invasion
but until that first missile was
launched into Ukraine many in truth
doubted Putin's illegal full-scale
Invasion would actually happen surely
this was just saber rattling they
thought
but it's important Madam Deputy speaker
to note that it was this country under
the leadership of my right honorable
friend uh The Honorable writable member
for South Uxbridge and South ruislip who
working with the United States exposed
the cynical Kremlin plan for a false
flag attack
involving planted fragments of uavs and
staged casualties in russian-occupied
territory to set up the phony pretext
for an invasion and on the 17th of
February the ministry of Defense
published The First Defense intelligence
showing Putin's planned Invasion Roots
just as the Russian president was
denying harboring any such intention
and indeed by the date of that
full-scale Invasion 22
000 Ukrainian service Personnel had
already been trained by British soldiers
across land across sea and in the air
weapons and ammunition including the now
famous end laws made here in the UK were
already in the hands of the Ukrainian
Army ready to defend that country from
the onslaught to come indeed the United
Kingdom was the first European country
to provide lethal defensive Aid
and how the ukrainians used it in those
vital first few weeks they used it to
hold back the Russian flood Russian
soldiers who Pat special uniforms for
the expected Victory Parade was stopped
in their tracks and instead were hurried
within an intensity and bravery that
stunned the world it was a feat of arms
against overwhelming odds that takes its
place in history
and then of course the Russian forces
were pushed back in a great sweeping
Retreat forced into a gruesome drive-by
past the scene of their many crimes not
least Butcher and named destined to
Forever stay in the conscience of the
Kremlin
Russian forces have now abandoned all
territory west of the nipma river at day
361 Russian forces are still not where
they expect to be on day three meanwhile
the combat effectiveness of their army
has been reduced by 40 percent nearly
two-thirds of their modern tanks have
been destroyed or disabled indeed
Putin's campaign appears to have failed
to meet any of its operational and
strategic objectives while Ukraine has
managed to wrestle back more than half
of its stolen territory
because despite all the bombast
despite the continued indiscriminate
assaults on civilians and civilian
infrastructure despite the repeated
human wave attacks with young men used
as cannon fodder Russia continues to
fail a little over a week and a half ago
a Russian Brigade attacking valedar was
completely wiped out losing more than a
thousand people in two days
those figures must be added to the
thousands and thousands that have gone
before
the Russian military has suffered up to
200 000 casualties including between 45
and 60 000 dead the blood price of a
perverse and a historical nationalist
fantasy
meanwhile Putin breaks his army on the
Anvil of Ukrainian resistance
ukrainians are displaced towns have been
raised to the ground and there are
credible reports of rapes in the forced
deportation of thousands of children and
there were those harrowing accounts
which were relayed by The Honorable
member for Bradford South don't forget
us she reminded some had said well we
won't
because those responsible for these
unspeakable acts will have to answer for
them indeed my right hand will found the
Deputy Prime Minister and the Minister
of Justice and security for the
Netherlands will be hosting the joint
ministerial Council in March to support
the vital work of the office of the
prosecutor and the international
criminal court and The Honorable
gentleman for strangford was right when
he referred to the systematic cruelty
let that be exposed let those crimes be
brought to Justice let people pay for
the cruelty and illegality they have
perpetrated
because just as time and again Russia
has reckoned without the courage to
nasty and indeed Ingenuity of the
Ukrainian people so too did Russia
underestimate the resolve and unity of
the International Community
I will
would he agree with me that when Putin
cowardly invaded Ukraine he thought the
West would look the other way a year on
he's probably deluded in believing that
we would be apathetic over time to the
support for Ukraine and what this debate
today and what the minute silence on
Friday will show is that we will never
give up Slava Ukraine
The Honorable gentleman puts the points
extremely well and I can't improve on
them because he's right today NATO is
stronger than ever and by the way it's
not just NATO we shouldn't fall into the
Trap of assuming it's NATO what about
Australia who is providing support to
the ukrainians what about the New
Zealand troops who here in the UK are
helping to train the ukrainians so let's
not give in to that puttanesque uh
rhetoric and narrative this is the world
Community coming together but it is a
fact that NATO is set to grow with the
accession of Sweden and Finland and the
UK alone has sanctioned almost 1300
individuals and over 130 entities since
the start The Invasion other countries
have acted decisively too and on this
issue of the Wagner group let me say we
have sanctioned both the Wagner group
we've sanctioned yogony pagosian we
sanctioned his family we sanctioned
Dimitri utkin also arcadi gospel the
director of the federal penitentiary
service of the Russian Federation
I will go ahead
while he's going through his list with
the minister be good enough just to
explain to the house why the Americans
have sanctioned three times more people
associated with the world group than we
have simple question
we have sanctioned the Wagner group in
its entirety so there really is no place
to hide yes we have and there is no
place to hide for those who either Aid
or a bet counsel or procure the actions
of the Wagner group and indeed the UK
has been amongst the foremost Nations
supporting Ukraine politically
militarily and with humanitarian
assistance too and it is worth just
taking a moment to consider what that
support actually involves so this is
over a hundred thousand rounds of
ammunition this is 5 000 anti-tank
weapons and on the point that was made
about armored vehicles the United
Kingdom has provided over 200 armored
fighting Vehicles some of the so-called
Dogs of War that Saw Service in
Afghanistan the Mastiffs the ridgehounds
uh the the the the Wolfhounds the
Ridgebacks and so on that is what we've
done to say nothing of the winter
weather gear to say nothing of the two
seeking helicopters to say nothing of
three million rounds of ammunition all
this we do and more
and we do so because we send a message
that might is not always right that the
international rules-based order stands
up stands for something and this country
will meet aggression where we find it
last month the defense secretary
announced we will be sending a
challenger to tanks and as90
self-propelled guns as I've indicated
that comes after endless javelins
Brimstone missiles night vision goggles
medical supplies winter clothing and
Search and Rescue helicopters the
training for the tank Crews has already
begun and while our armed forces are
also putting Ukrainian recruits through
their Paces in a range of critical
crucial Battlefield skills and I would
just share it with the house this there
is
there are a few more poignant sites
Madam Deputy speaker when flying over
some of those training grounds and
seeing Ukrainian troops beneath you to
see scarred etched into those fields of
the United Kingdom trenches and indeed
that is what it has become trench
warfare in parts of our continent so in
2022 we train 10 000 new troops in 2023
we intend to double that number and as
honorable members will also be aware our
Armed Forces will be training Ukrainian
aviators to fly sophisticated NATO
standard fighters in the future we
expect to begin training the first
Ukrainian Pilots this spring you cannot
of course Supply a jet before you've
trained the pilot and no time is being
wasted in that endeavor and we have
committed to match the 2.3 billion
pounds of military aid spent last year
and that's why we continue to lead the
international military and do and
diplomatic effort too as we saw with our
tank donations as The Honorable member
for Iranian Wickford indicated our role
can be to have a force multiplier effect
we can catalyze the work of other
nations that's why the Prime Minister
signed the London declaration with
President zielinski cementing our
unwavering commitment to Ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
and urging others to do the same there
is much more I could talk about but let
me just come to this Mr Speaker on
Friday the nation will stand in silence
to commemorate a year on from The
Invasion as well as his majesty the king
sending his support to Ukraine over a
hundred events will take place across
Whitehall this will be an opportunity to
remember all those who've lost their
lives and all those who have seen their
lives irrevocably changed it will be an
opportunity to remember all those who
continue to fight for their Liberty but
it will also be an opportunity Madam
Deputy speaker to redouble our resolve
assuring that when the time comes that
proud Nation will build back stronger
than before which is why on the 21st and
22nd of June the United Kingdom jointly
with Ukraine will host the international
Ukraine recovery conference
Mr Madam Deputy speaker the signal we
are sending to Vladimir Putin couldn't
be clearer he has turned his country
into a pariah and the most sanctioned
Nation on the planet
meanwhile the world stands with Ukraine
ready to support that proud and defined
country to defend its territory and its
people
one year on with Russia gearing up for a
new offensive Putin remains unrepentant
his only coherent War aims are for more
war more death and more suffering his
desperate hope is that the world will
lose its nerve it won't
together we will defy him together we
will prove him wrong as president
zielinski told us in his stirring
address of the house two weeks ago we
know Freedom will win we know Russia
will lose
and we really know the victory the
victory will change the world slable
cleaning Slava
[Applause]
the question is that this house has
considered the situation in
Ukraine as many as are of that opinion
say I I the country know I think the
eyes have it the eyes have it